the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
the stars of us chess are ready for
their close-ups at the U.S women's and
U.S open championships in St Louis the
nation's best are ready to shine under
the bright lights of the chess Capital
Hans Neiman is no stranger to the
spotlight and looks primed for a leading
role defeating U.S junior Champion
Christopher you to join Sam sebian for
co-lead of the event the Women's
Championship is rolling with a talented
Ensemble of leading ladies lighting up
the standings after winning their games
that's a wrap on day one day two of
action-packed Chess coming up next
[Music]
all right
[Music]
welcome back everybody to day two of the
2022 us Chess Championship and U.S
women's chess Championships held here at
the St Louis chess club we started the
in front of the World Chess Hall of Fame
as we are waiting for the players to
arrive it was a fantastic day one and
we're sure to follow it up with an
incredible day too let's go to the
studio and start the action with Yasser
and anastasi
from the home of Chess in the United
States welcome to the Saint Louis chess
club and the second round of the USGS
championships and the U.S women's chess
championships
[Music]
hello everyone I'm Anastasia carlowicz
and I'm here with my brilliant co-host
Yasser ceravan I was going to say the
same thing about you Anastasia you stole
the words right out of my mouth yes so
that's a pleasure to be here with you
yesterday thank you hello everyone and
Welcome to our show well round one of
the US Championship certainly delivered
some excellent chess I really really
enjoyed it two victories in the open
section four in the ladies and Anastasia
do the honors who are our leaders thank
you yes sir let's check first women's
section yeah right so we have four
leaders four girls managed to win
yesterday
Jennifer you was the second one Ellis
Lee and we also have Megan Lee so four
of them they scored one point exactly
and uh following closely yeah half a
point behind her email
Sabina and in the open
in the open section we have the same
stadium
the early co-leaders in the tournament
that won their games yesterday yeah and
a big chasing pack at a half a point
here the heavy Wesley we're near Jeffrey
Sam Ray darush Lavon and Alex and a
Wonder All a half a point and the format
for this Marathon events it's really
Marathon yes yes I remember we have 14
players around Robin tournaments so 90
minutes for the first 40 moves and Then
followed by 30 minutes for the rest of
the game everyone will have 30 seconds
increment from move one and of course no
drawers fighting until the end and our
schedule
and the schedule we have second round
today we're already on 6th of October
and then we have two rest days on 10th
and 16th of October in case if we have
playoffs it's gonna take place on 20th
of October wonderful and as always we're
happy to have in studio Christian good
afternoon my friend what do you have for
us today good afternoon guys great to be
back in the casting Booth casting the
games of the 28 best chess players that
we have here on American soil and what
an amazing start to this two events has
been yesterday just topsy-turvy very
exciting games but it is too early to
already think about champions for this
year's event but what we can do is think
about champions of the past and I want
to talk a little bit about that we're
going to start with the ladies section
and we see some very familiar names in
that one Jennifer shahadi that we all
know so well here in Saint Louis Arena
crush a Time National Champion Anna
zatonski four-time National Champion
Sabina foia short and Jenny for you are
all national champions and are playing
in this year's event unfortunately
Carissa Eve was uh unable to join us for
this year due to her her academic career
and let's take a look at what's
happening in the open section and who
are the Champions the big champions of
the past of course we see that big first
name Bobby Fisher a Time National
Champion gatakomski five-time national
champion and one uh yes sir do you guys
know who that is Hikaru Nakamura Fabiano
caruana Wesley so and Sam Shanklin just
incredible players all around and a lot
of them are here battling for the
championship in this year's competition
and let's take a look at what their ages
are as well going into this event and
the big discrepancy that we see here in
the ladies section we see anazatasky
Irina Crush Tate abrahamian their uh age
is the highest but also their rating is
the highest at the bottom of the table
we see Alice Lee she is only 12 years of
age to be honest I don't remember
playing national championships when I
was 12 years of age just an incredible
player and there she is
abrahamian she has the experience on her
side and well I definitely will be
looking at her games and let's take a
look at Men's ages as well we have Levon
aronia and the birthday boy actually
today is his birthday 40 years young
Lanier Dominguez 39 elshon Morada 37 and
we have Christopher you the newly minted
U.S junior Champion only 15 years of age
a big eclectic mix of Youth and
experience we have here at the
Championships and there he is the
birthday boy with the shark shirt that's
an interesting one shark and bats is
that it
nice 40 years young our congratulations
to Lavon said at the table for us uh
Anastasia if you would the pairings for
the ladies for round two yeah we have
second round today and Jennifer you
place white with uh Yank on the first
board and then we have uh Sophia playing
against Talia and then Alice against the
uh
I got that yes yes
and night he plays against Megan Lee
you're in a crush plays against Sabina
for sure A Clash of former Champions yes
exactly and another tonski four-time U.S
Champion plays against
and there's our youngest participant in
the tournament 12 years old Alice Lee
who is
high for first uh remarkable and in the
open section uh the parents for round
two for them
will play today with his shark with all
his sharks against the linear domingue
because actually his friend right and
then Ray Robson will face Fabiano
caruana a battle of Olympic teammates
yes
another U.S Champion Hans Neiman will
face Jeff fiction today Young Generation
leaders and Wesley saw faces Christopher
you and Sean will play with abander and
Alex will play against them seven
absolutely wonderful games
and here is a World Chess Hall of Fame
inductee eugeno Torre a great Legend
from the Philippines with his wife
Marlene
and uh well he made a very beautiful
heartfelt speech for his induction uh 12
times in a row a clean dozen he missed
misread singfield
it was good it was great the way he did
it though and I think Wesley mentioned
yesterday he played in 22 olympiads it's
unbelievable
not keeping in mind that the olympiads
are held every two years
right career and let's not forget we
missed one Olympiad as well because of
kovit he didn't have one so exactly it's
really impressive really really
remarkable I played with Eugene Torre in
London in the Phillips and Drew and we
played in the Parliament building and
our hotel was on the other side of Hyde
Park so he walked in the middle of the
night through the hotel to our
through the park to our hotel and he
serenaded me with the song My Way
by and he was brilliant wow oh my God
Frank Sinatra never sang it so well it
was it was unbelievable I was he's
really a fabulous singer as well and
there we see the players getting their
game faces off as Darius says virch
fighting against the 2018 U.S Champion
snapshot what are they yeah they're
focused Christian they're concentrating
what they what are they doing they're
just refreshing uh what they're
expecting I think at this point they
just want to get the game started you
still have those butterflies as you
enter the playing hall waiting and
waiting to start the game you know
you're not going to speak with your
opponent you're just sitting face to
face right kind of this awkward exchange
waiting for uh the battle to commence
and uh of course they are trying to
remember that theory as well they're
probably strategizing how are they going
to handle if their opponent surprises
them first and things of that nature but
definitely what it's on their mind and
what they want right now is to start the
game wonderful that we see our defending
Champion Wesley so getting ready for
play I think what we ought to do is one
of us should go into the playing Hall
with as many electronic devices as you
possibly could and just test the
destination
make sure that uh those wands are
working for you I've tried them before
but I think we have extra equipments yes
so maybe we have to go through this
stage exactly check how does it feel I
know that for example all players they
leave their electronic devices and the
building of the club
wondering where her opponent is as the
games have got underway we heard the
gong by the way uh I saw in the playing
Hall one of the people uh from the media
um they're Bryce he came on Set uh
yesterday and are we going to see a
groomfield yes by Sam Shanklin by Sam
Shanklin since when does Sam play the
groomfield he used to play only the
semi-slav and he has a brilliant uh
course on chessball on the semi-slave
exactly now he's playing the that that's
good news to me
now you can see what Sam has been
studying and by the way this is a major
major
defense it's not like you just say oh
one day I want to wake up and I want to
play the groom show not possible no it's
just then you just lose it yeah there's
just so many systems
oh this is what's going on a lot of the
players are in queue waiting to be
wanded in it with 28 participants
it takes a while that's why Sabina was
waiting she was waiting for arena Crush
actually I see you see Christopher
Hans is there as well I think there's a
message in all of this arrive earlier
than
you expect arrive 15 minutes earlier
right that's the best but you know chess
players like to be late
I was always the opposite I love to be
at least five minutes early the reason
was I wanted to sit down
I wanted to have my score sheet all
ready with my pen and I wanted to just
soak in the tournament Hall all the
tournament Halls that I've ever played
in all have noises and I wanted to
customize myself to whether it be an air
conditioning noise or a fan or squeaky
yes I mean it's important squeaky
floorboards I didn't want to have my
game right next to a squeaky book
because whenever anybody came over to
look at your game right
crunch that's very very distracting and
check this out uh both darouche and Sam
are just whipping through uh their moves
uh Christian uh you're our resident
expert on the groomfield take us through
what uh what's the latest and greatest
in this line absolutely give me just one
second to pick up at that game yes so
Bishop to E3 this bishop to C4 line has
become quite popular in recent times and
in fact Darius also he's not necessarily
a big D4 player well sure he plays it
occasionally but he's mostly an E4
player and he actually wrote books about
E4 he has two tremendous volumes on E4
E5 and the real Lopez and everything
that is encompassed in that opening
nevertheless if I have to pick one of
the players that is probably one of uh
the best prepared in this event is
Darius Verge and maybe Sam Shanklin as
well so they're definitely going into a
big theoretical battle Bishop to E3 now
Queen to C7 you can play a lot of things
B6 became popular recently I think it
was popularized if I'm not mistaken by
Maxim vashir lagrav one gruffal player
massive even he doesn't play the
Greenfield as often anymore Peter's
wheeler I think generally goes for the
bishop G4 lines Bishop to G4 and after
that Bishop to D7 after the move F3
there's a lot of ways in which you can
play at this position so let's take a
look at how they continued E6 now this
is quite an unusual wrinkle you don't
want to uh hurry with the move E6 at
some point sure you're going to play
that in order to stop the move D5 you're
not actually stopping it but if they
decide to play A5 then you can at least
exchange the E7 with the E4 pawn and
open up the e-file for your Rook which
generally is good for black also the
pawn on D5 is not going to protect it by
another Pawn at least momentarily unless
white manages to push this Pawn from C3
to C4 and create that pass Pawn on D5
very very powerful passport on D5 now
let's take a look at what happened E6
preventing that move D5 D takes C5 now
this is a momentary Pawn sacrifice at
some point Queen takes d8 Rook takes d8
Rook 2 D1 and Bishop to D7 at some point
Bishop to B3 and they're still within
their theoretical knowledge even though
there are no games left let me see where
was the first novelty Knight to E5 still
Queen takes d8 in fact was a novelty
that's quite unusual unexpected
um Bishop to B3 was played in previous
games one of them is Knight ditch versus
McShane but all of them are quite old
games knightage versus McShane all the
way in 2006 so this hasn't been played
in a long time this move E6 but
definitely with the emergence of new
engines a lot of things that didn't work
let's say five years ago right now work
you can make them work and this is
exactly what Sam Shanklin is doing with
his opening Choice Bishop to B3 is what
we have on the board right now white is
a pawn up but I will find a way to uh
Corral this Pawn on C5 I'm going to go
Rook to C8 Bishop to f8 and then this
Pawn on C5 is going to be very difficult
to defend now in the meantime what white
wants to do is set up an attack on the B
file the B7 for the moment is the
weakness in Black's position if I manage
to get to that B7 Pawn Rook to B1 up to
situ or something along those lines and
not allow you to capture on C5 having
you to defend the pawn on B7 first and
forget about my weakness on C5 then
maybe I will be able to preserve my
material advantage even though they're
double pawns they're still uh it's still
a pawn up so that's pretty good right
and also you have this very important
Square for the Knight Knight comes to a
d4m could potentially set up some
unpleasantries against the bishop on C6
very interesting choice for Sam Shanklin
of the opening for Sam Shanklin but he
does seem to know what he needs to do in
this line so I'm expecting him to
probably equalize this one what's the
current evaluation after this let's take
a look heavyweight duel let's take a
look
um the engine is saying 0.5 now
the engine usually in this type of
positions with an extra Pawn does say
0.5 0.4 but if you go along and we know
how deep the preparation can go for this
top level players if you go along for
another 10 moves at some point it
stabilizes around 0.2 and you understand
it's pretty much a technical uh equality
if not a technical draw so I think this
is what Sam is trying to get out of this
game and also Darius is playing for two
results it's very difficult to be worse
in this end game with the white pieces
so he's not taking any unnecessary risks
most likely he was surprised by Sam
shanklin's opening choice so right now
he chose an opening that suits his style
and Suits this specific encounter with a
player that surprised him
thank you Christian indeed and for those
of you who are joining us late first of
all shame on you but secondly to let you
know that there seemed to be a line in
security so some of the games are still
in the early stages I wanted to say that
in the game of elshon versus a Wonder
Liang it's a zeitz variation of the rule
Lopez and after the move Bishop B7 I
actually worked with Jan Timon for his
1993 World Championship match against
Anatoly karpov and we worked on the zeit
set yeah
two months and we found some really
really nice ideas no we didn't refute
the zaitsap but we found some really
nice ideas for white and always and I
mean always our analysis began with D4
Rook E8 like this was our tabia position
and then we went A4 and Bishop f8 and
boy did we go deep deep down the rabbit
hole for me the move a to A4 obviously
they play everything in the opening and
this is not a novelty at all but it's
just such a surprise because everything
white has done up to this moment
including the move C3 including the
moves H3 has been with one goal one
purpose to get the Central Pawn Duo to
grab the space in the center and instead
A2 A4 which is why I wanted to ask
Christian is this the latest and
greatest in zaitsev A4 it's it's uh it's
a wrinkle it's not the greatest and
latest but it is something that is
supported uh by the engines I was going
through the lines it does seem like
Knight to A5 and you mentioned you guys
were starting the analysis after D4 and
Rook to EA yes this was the starting
point of your analysis now let's take a
look at what's happening after A4 Knight
to A5 seems to be the best best move and
after Bishop to C2 C5 once you play the
Knight to A5 you generally want to
follow that up with C5 so that whenever
this Knight gets attacked you go back to
C6 but you're behind the pawn and you
have more space this is uh crucial in
this type of structures but now after D4
there's no more Rook E8 so the position
is a little bit different if you do go
Rook to E8 I'm not even going to take
only five what I am going to do I'm
going to go D5 and take advantage of the
fact that not only your knight is a
little bit misplaced on the rim and it's
going to take a while to get it back
into the game actually this is a known
square that you don't want to see the
Knight on whenever you're seeing this
Pawn on uh D5 generally you want to go
back via C4 to B6 if you cannot get to
B6 then you're going to actually have to
go all the way to F7 to get back into
the game Knight to B7 Knight to d8 F6 or
F5 and Knight to F7 and not even then
you're getting back into the game with
that Knight so this is one of the the
potential bad pieces that black has to
worry about in this type of structures
now once you play D4 Rook 38 is not
possible in general you have to change
your strategy you can go Queen to C7 but
once again that allows the move D5 and
then what are you going to do with the
Knight or you can just simply take on D4
but leads this uh leads to completely
different situations and different
structures uh maybe not similar to
something that he looked at in the game
preparation of Wonderland that is so
maybe quite a nicer price by elshon
moradia body to start this big battle
against a wonder and it does seem to
have produced some results because the
Wonder is taking a long thing absolutely
um one of the real issues for one E2 E4
players Anastasia beside the Berlin
let's get a close-up there is of a
Wonder Liang is the Petrov or what we
call the Petrov what do we call Russians
and linear
Dominguez after working with Bobby
adopted the petrol he's been doing
really wonderfully well on the black
side
it's brought him
rather comfortable equality I want to
say in the majority of the games and
he's even won some when his opponent
overpresses so here's Levon facing this
very solid
defense and we're about to see a wrinkle
that is unfamiliar to me the move Knight
E5 so for the moment it's almost like
the beat of a drum for that single
moment the black king is still in the
center and thanks to this Rook on the
e-file it presents a few problems uh for
black that his King is still in the
center for example the desirable Knight
takes E5 Rook takes E5 Queen back Queen
to E2 and Hallelujah there's some
difficulties
yeah it's not the end of the game you
would play probably yeah but I mean even
the crossing maybe with some rookie
eight ideas is it possible it's a piece
but it's a rookie one so no it's not
possible to take Queen E8 no
no um
so I thought about take first queen E8
and then locate it attack on E7 yes A7
you're sorry okay and then but then it's
a pcsu right just to check yes yes no
not at all these things you you always
need to check it always always so
there's a slight issue here for uh
Lanier he can't Castle because his
Bishop is hanging after Knight takes C6
oops see Daisy so Lanier uh drops back
with the Knight
then another tickle Queen came to C3
so in the immortal words of Nikolai
benev gift meet the palm
no you can't have it Knight to E6 we've
caught up with the players but I'm
sitting here looking at this move Queen
B3 and again it's one of those things
can I exploit the fact that the king is
still in the center
well uh
probably you should Castle I think it's
too dangerous for you to reach across
the board and grab this Pawn after a
move like Knight takes
D4 Queen A5 check might hurt Lanier's
feelings but
definitely definitely but here's here
was my thought process it went like this
Castle short maybe castles long is
better here's my tricky are you ready
for my tricky Queen takes D5 Rook d8
yeah yes
I see six oh
just hanging my queen but attacking the
bishop you can take my queen either way
but at the end of the day I'll end up
with an extra Pawn for all the hard work
that we did in the opening again the
theory marches so fast that and there he
is
uh our birthday boy uh Lavon 40 years
young congratulations
one of the top players in the world and
I mean he has the nicest persons you'll
ever meet in the Chess World exactly it
is really really uh an outstanding
personality
um a Christian if I could ask you uh has
Lavon discovered a way of getting
advantage against the Russian defense
it's so hard no no
the simple answer is no no absolutely
not um so I think he wanted
was that the move yes that was my great
idea now after Queen to B3 you do attack
both pawns right correct we were
discussing about castle and that's a
beautiful trick by the way very nice
Queen takes D5 Rook da Knight to C6 that
definitely works now the problem is
after uh Queen to B3 I can go the other
way long Castle wow my knight is on E6
everything is protected this actually
protects two pawns at the same time
right I'm protecting D5 with the Rook B7
with the King a very nice move and it's
very difficult for you to actually get
an attack going because you still
haven't finished your development not
only that but you also have let's say
beautiful Knight on E5 but sometimes
this could become a bit overextended
night right because I'm going to go Rook
to E8 Bishop to D6 targeted and also you
have to deal with the pawn on D4 you
have to develop and uh defend that at
the same time it's not as easy for
example if you go Bishop to E3 to try to
do both of those things I'm going to
attack this Knight and put a lot of
pressure in at the center you don't have
time to stabilize and you don't have
time to play what you probably want to
play in the position and that is C4 open
up the C file and try to get an attack
against the King on C8 so my king long
Castle on the queen side is just such an
amazing uh secured piece now on the
other hand if you do go back for example
with the Knight Knight to D3 I'm
starting to look at your H2 Pawn I'm
starting to look at your king I can
tickle you with Queen to H5 if you go H3
I have G5 G4 coming and I'm going to
take advantage of that hook that you
just created The Pawn on H3 if you go G3
I'm going to move the queen away H5 H4
open up the H file and I think with the
black pieces and according to the
engines that is the correct assessment
black is faster in this position so
Queen to B3 perhaps you're not looking
in the right direction and you were
asking me whether there's any advantage
any objective advantage in the position
not so much absolutely not
what I wanted to point out is the fact
that linear actually started with two
blacks against Fabiano caruana in which
he had a devastating position actually
he was winning a good advantage that a
game close to winning objectively sure
maybe from a practical perspective it
was just better but from an objective
perspective it was actually winning
that's because Fabiano messed up his uh
preparation forgot his preparation we
discussed it after the game oops also
right now he's playing with the black
pieces against Levon aronian the
newcomer and one of the best players in
the field so if he starts with a solid
draw against Fabiano in a solid draw
against Iranian world that's a good sign
for Lanier right right yes but I was
wondering yes Airman eleven has birthday
today is it easy normally to play when
you have your birthday or you want to
finish the game and go to celebrate
precisely I'm in the ladder Camp I I
didn't I did okay on my birthday mostly
because I want wanted to get out of
there make a draw and and as you say go
celebrate but I don't know a lot of
people seem to think like their birthday
is their lucky day and they're pushing
you have to push yes they have to get
the present right exactly uh but how
about yourself did you like playing on
your birthday I don't remember actually
I don't recall playing on my birthday
what I remember actually that the world
champion Magnus Carlson always plays on
his birthday because the world
championship matches happen to be at the
same time and I remember that he won his
match against Sergey correct in 2016 on
his birthday delivering this queen H6
last year November yes that one and also
I remember him playing as well the world
championship the last one against Yani
promise in Dubai and there were many
discussions also that he has to play on
his birthday and if the team of Nepal
prepared the the cake or they will share
the cake and things like that so I mean
there were many speculations about it as
well birthdays uh they're awkward days
uh let's just go around the horn after
uh
the it looks like everybody got through
security check by the way I mean as we
know it's not so easy let's start with
the game uh between Hans and Jeffrey
this is uh a French defense a Mainline
Old Line Stein it's uh with Knight F6
not the not the winner world that we see
after the move Bishop B4 Bishop B4 more
or less a modern approach uh that's been
popular for 100 years but E5 oh and I
used to play this a lot as black and I
didn't play the move Queen V6 quite so
much
um as Bishop to C5 that was my choice
here Queen B6 a little bit of a wrinkle
for me uh Queen B6 Queen and
no Hans stopped yeah Queen B6
um
because well yeah let's see so he's
thinking to himself okay I'm used to
Bishop C5 uh how do I take advantage of
this if I go Knight A4 yes which defends
the pawn on B2 attacks the queen it will
precipitate with Queen uh check and then
after C3 Knight takes D4 now you usually
have to be a little bit uh aware of
these ideas of B5 at least and
b2b4 I'm getting I'm going down a rabbit
hole that I really don't know that very
well Queen B6 has got Hans thinking
we're going to come back as we just go
again around the horn there's darouche
this is the uh Sam Shanklin ending is
Sam is looking to round up this Pawn on
C6 maybe with ideas of Bishop f8 and
Knight D7 as well by the way he moved
his Rook to see it yesterday to see it I
think was the last movie Yes interesting
I think very deep but also look at his
time yes Sam hasn't spent any of his
time he knows exactly where he is yeah
very good I like this and this is the
elshon one now I wonder after the move
A2 A4 I wonder uh transposed the game
into a kind of a brayer with the move
Knight B8 as opposed to the zaitsev with
rookie brayer sees the night getting
deployed we just saw a Christian explain
that oftentimes after Knight A5
sometimes the Knight gets stranded on A5
not so when the night is on D7 by the
way gift me the pollen stop and think
about that Lavon Lanier we've been
talking about that Bishop D2 Lanier says
pardon me Levon says I'm not going for
the queen B3 and maybe losing a Tempo
and seeing Newcastle long I'll just play
Bishop D2
doesn't look like he has much of an
advantage if you ask me Wesley so versus
Christopher you again we see the
popularity of the Russian defense it
waxes and wanes uh some great players in
the past love to play the Russian
including Anatoly karpov Boris gelfin
many others and then everybody is like
everybody left
went on an exit and went into the night
or
and now they're back their heart is back
yes it's a fashion right right 15 years
young Christopher you my goodness uh as
he is he goes up against the reigning
champion and finally Sam Savion who is
tied for the first going into this game
this looks like a yes it's a Catalan
very topical ending that has appeared in
well I want to say quite a number of
games and that's our trip around the
horn for the men shall we take a look at
the ladies of course why not
and we'll start with uh
this game between Naji and Megan this is
from a rule for me it's a scotch yes it
came from Scorch and uh it was it's very
funny uh the scotch really reintroduced
if you will by Gary Kasparov and I
remember
that in the old days uh CTC yeah it was
the automatic movement everybody went
for C4 and then uh people would play
Bishop A6 and this was important to keep
the Knight as long on D5 as you can by
pitting the pawn and I remember a friend
John Vanderbilt a Grandmaster from
Holland played the move H2 H4 in one of
his games and I said John
what the heck is H4 what's the idea
behind H4 he said well yeah sir
brokerage three yes yes Rook A3
hits the bishop
who picks this stuff up no we didn't
have that what we did have however was
uh partly what we did have was H4 Queen
E2 Knight D5
H4 right away preparing C4 but then uh
Queen E6 uh steps out of the way so that
the Knight can come back to E7 now I
don't know how effective is the Pawn on
H4 Knight B4 94th written in that City I
mean I don't know we ever played all
this before
the the Scottish Scotch opening is one
of those openings where
uh it it kind of defies understanding
you just have to study a great deal a
move like Queen F5 threatening Knight C2
what I discovered when I was studying
games of Gary Kasparov you know what's a
really really really strong move is King
D1 you sit there and you go well isn't
it terrible that you've been forced to
lose castling privilege just yes it is
terrible but on the other hand losing a
rook is worse it's like you stop that
and you prepare A3 and somehow Black's
pieces are discombobulated the scotch
defense Scotch opening is tough I was
thinking not only that if just to show
to the wizard or to the viewers like
after Queen F5 Knight D4 is not possible
probably right or or it is instead of
King D1 no it's I'm sure it's possible
this second yes there is a trick or what
like that's annoying hold on no then
it's just enough I thought about 93 but
but it's not possible because it's a
queen so maybe 94 is possible what did
she prepare for uh I can only guess that
what she intends therefore is probably
the move C5
in order to stop and also to kind of
make room very good yeah to to to drop
back with the knight uh we'll keep an
eye on this one as we go to a game of
Sofia and tell you this is a again very
topical open Sicilian
um
I always like the center having the
center pawns I know this variation is
probably considered even it's just that
I just I have an affinity with the
center I like it a lot and I think that
uh Italia is actually just doing fine uh
in this position Alice Lee one of our
leaders going up against Bigham who led
the U.S Olympic team in India
and performed incredibly well on board
one absolutely there is actually yes
airplane yes it's interesting how Ellis
will handle or how she will play this
game exactly one of the top players of
U.S exactly uh Queen's camper had
accepted even ending let's go to
Jennifer and ruyang oh okay this is this
is my stuff Old Line nimzo uh oops
excuse me I wanted to go
slower through that Queen C2 classical
variation castles
remember playing against Michael Tal
played D5 c d e d Bishop G5 and he
played with me H6 and there's some
really really sharp variations with
Bishop
H4 I looked across the board saw Michael
tal was my opponent
I'm taking this knife we're trading off
as many pieces as I can
um
exactly no Checkmate for you okay
winning the two Bishops and Bishop G5
and we're up to date in a very topical
line of the um
classical
more or less used to seeing B6 and C5
from black in these variations let's
keep let's keep going as we go to Arena
and again we mentioned that this is The
Clash of former Champions as we came on
the show a Christian introduced The
Glorious path yes exactly yes both of
them were US Champions and batarino
eight times that that's something that
is very very special indeed
um well Central Pawn Duo for black she
had to give up the two Bishops
um I kind of like this imbalance
position I would say uh both players are
more or less happy they've gotten out of
the opening with pretty balanced game I
would just say and then finally and
lastly we have Rochelle versus shritha
and ooh Christian jump in on this one
this one definitely went off the rails
for me
that seems to be some theoretical battle
right I'm sorry ashrita just not
spending any of her time up to this
point Bishop to E2 maybe this surprise
her a little bit but night way for makes
a lot of sense right you're targeting
the pawn on C3 and to be honest
how are you defending that was why I
wanted you to come in and bail me out
because I wasn't too sure my guess is
that you want to take on D5 and then
continue with C4 okay get out you don't
need to defend it you just didn't get to
get rid of it uh
right aren't they walking it aren't I
inviting yeah I have to say for the
black side now another way maybe I can
continue after night wave for and
perhaps this
forces some sort of an equality can I go
Bishop D3
Bishop partly we just came from there I
think right and and I'm wondering
whether you have to go back or you can
take and now F3 and this is the uh
this is a probable well I mean you still
have Queen B6 yes Bishop to E3 and then
we play this I do have Knight F5 coming
so
maybe maybe I have something
I could be hanging my whole position
here right after Bishop D3 you are
inviting the rap exactly exactly Bishop
to D3 knight from A4 goes back to C5 and
that invites a repetition
um whether that's going to be the case
or not we'll have to wait and see one of
the things that strikes me is a little
odd is that the positions of these
Knights for uh just a moment
um like if I did something really stupid
probably to move like F2 F3 forced you
to take
it
yeah I'd almost pleased to get rid of
this F3 Pawn so I could somehow uh this
night somehow yes maybe bishop Detroit
well yeah I wanted to Rook but uh it's
just like one of these things it does
occur to me that the the black king
doesn't have a lot of Palace guards but
that's okay yeah I'll take on C4 and I
don't know if you want to take an
adventure oh H7 okay trade okay how do
you continue I know the problem is I've
got my own awkward uh grouping of pieces
don't exactly yeah and and the reason
why I think black is doing just fine
yeah if maybe not even better is that I
think I can go Queen B6
this is what I saw Queen B2 and we
forced the trade of the Queens I'm not
even going to start looking at your
Bishop on H7 try to trap it with you yes
yes I don't want to play yeah okay maybe
it's good objectively but I don't want
to even think about it yeah I I yeah I I
certainly in this variation most
especially I haven't exploited the fact
that well your king is a little maybe
now after you take on D5 now Bishop D3
is it Improvement an improvement or not
if you take taken now Bishop D3 I tend
to think not just because I see these
Rook C8 coming in at times it gets me
not not right now not Rook see it right
now
um even though maybe it's worth even
again you go back yes and then you want
to draw I think Lavon aronian and
Alexander London from round one and uh
yes
okay maybe first actually yeah or even
Rook CA yeah well uh tell us what has
caught your eye and these 14 games that
uh well actually the game that you guys
have started with the one between Hans
and Jeffrey because this is a very
topical line this queen to B6 has become
one of the main lines of this particular
uh French and it strikes me as a bit odd
that Hans taught for a very long time
for this move A3 now let's try to
understand what's happening in the
position
at this point white has a couple of
options A3 is one of them but it has
been played only 44 times compared to
the main line which is Queen to D2 Queen
to D2 has been played 400 plus times in
the database and it leads to a very
forced line now you cannot go Bishop to
C5 anymore and try to force my hand
about the Knight on D4 I'm not going to
Castle but I do have now that you no
longer have any checks on A5 I have this
move Knight to A4 I'm going to capture
the bishop you're not losing a piece or
anything of that nature but you're much
worse once I managed to get your Bishop
you're going to be much worse Queen to
B4 take on C5 take on C5 and then uh
with uh without the presence of dark
Square Bishop your key squares
especially this score D6 around your
king is going to be extremely extremely
vulnerable so you cannot do that you
cannot go Bishop C5 after Queen to D2
you have to go Queen takes B2 and this
leads to that long variation that a lot
of people know night uh Bishop to B5
Knight takes before Bishop takes D4 A6
Bishop D7 Bishop takes D7 now you have a
couple of options as white Rook to B3 or
Rook takes B7 directly both of them
actually leading to different type of
positions for example if you take on B7
uh directly black has to go Bishop to B4
if you do start off with Rook to B3 in
general black response with the move
Queen to E7 this is considered to be
okay for black in fact considered to be
okay for black if they know what they're
doing if they know the precise move
order and the exact Theory so it does
seem like Jeffrey knows what he's doing
because he's been blissing out his moves
he decided for this move Queen to B6 and
at this point Hans started thinking and
he played this move A3
a very intriguing move the question is
what did you after Bishop to C5 which
was played in the game yeah Knight wave
four sorry not night wave four Knight
wave four we would have led uh to
probably just a simple draw after going
to A5 you have to drop back to C3 I
don't think he want to play B4 because
after Queen takes A4 you take on C5 but
I take back on C5 and it does seem like
this leads to a very good position Pawn
up for a black shirt white has some
compensation due to the fact that I no
longer have dark Square Bishop but I
don't think it's enough Knight takes C5
and it's very key that after Knight
takes E5 I can just simply take back
with the queen and defend the Knight on
C5 at the same time so you cannot do
that nevertheless after Knight to A4
Queen to A5 Knight to C3 that forces a
draw so Hans decided against it he
played the move Knight cb5 and this is a
key moment right now for a black what is
Jeffrey going to do is he going to go A6
A6 after B4 I'm looking at the position
and after eight is B5 take on C5 Queen
takes C5 five sure the engine is saying
zero zero zero but it does feel like
it's so much easier to play from the
white side I am going to regain my Pawn
on B5 I'm going to restore the material
balance and after that I'm going to have
this key Square D6 that I'm going to be
able to invade with my knight if you
don't trade on D4 and if you do trade on
D4 then I'm going to have two Bishops
against bishop and Knight I'm going to
pick up the pawn on B5 and it does feel
like white has more space has the two
Bishops so why not uh AC better in this
position at least from a practical
perspective forget about the engine eval
I think from practical perspective this
one feels better for Hans at this
particular moment but we had a fun
exchange yesterday in our direct
interview after his victory against
Christopher you let's take a look
we are with Hans Niemann after an
incredible Victory with the black pieces
against a fellow Junior Christopher you
Hans first of all let's address the
elephant in the room you've been under a
lot of pressure tell us a bit about that
well um I think that this game is a
is a message to everyone and uh you know
this entire thing started with me saying
chess speaks for itself and uh I think
this game spoke for itself and showed
the chess player that I am and it also
showed that um I'm not going to back
down and I'm going to play my best chess
here regardless of the pressure that I'm
under and that's all I have to say about
this game and
you know
chess speaks for itself you know that's
all I can say let's discuss the game a
little bit that's it but uh you know you
can leave it to your interpretation but
thank you that is that's it all you want
to say yes because it was such a
beautiful game I don't even need to
describe it
thank you
a beautiful game that defied description
Christian it's actually uh just cut off
before you left and we wanted to get
your question in there right yes what
was the question
I was going to take on D5 couldn't get
in it uh this position reminds me of an
end game that I like to play as black
the the position that Hans has with
Jeffrey and the ending that I like to
play as black would go Knight takes D4
Bishop takes D4 Bishop takes D4 Queen
takes D4 Queen takes D4 Knight takes D4
King he said you like to play this as
black I like to play this as black and
the idea is pretty simple I was going to
play Knight B6 and Bishop D7 and the
funny part is I would play for G5
oops which is uh rather rather uh in
obvious and the fact that white has
already played the move a2a3 is kind of
a bonus for uh me but uh what is the
theoretical you mentioned that a7a6
could end up seeing Jeffrey I'm not a
big fan of a7a6 again this is the
computer recommendation uh from a
practical perspective I don't like it
personally I don't like it maybe Jeffrey
likes it maybe Jeffrey likes to play
without dark Square Bishop in that
particular case then he would go for A6
but Knight to day four uh Knight takes
D4 the move that you recommended the
answer is also one of the main lines in
the position Bishop takes a D4 and
actually not Bishop takes D4 it seems
like this end game after Queen takes D4
Knight takes D4 King to E7 H4 yeah
particularly against you right now
is saying that black is uh on the back
foot right at this point quite badly in
fact because at some point you will have
to play the move F6 try to break in uh
the center the problem is I don't have
any weaknesses as white I'm going to be
able to just simply develop my pieces go
Bishop to D3 put some pressure on H7
actually that's quite important because
your Rook is going to have to guard that
pawn on H7 I will be able to take it if
you move it away and then when you try
to trap it with G6 I'm going to
immediately hook it with H5 and get my
Bishop out so you have to be careful if
you do play H6 after Bishop to D3 then
you're going to have some problems on
the light squares so it does seem like
this position is favorable this end game
is favorable for white now the question
is how can you sidestep all of this I
think after Knight takes D4 Bishop takes
D4 what you can do is wait for white to
force you to take on D4 and improve the
position in the meantime with the move
short castle if you do go B4 then I will
take on D4 you take back with a queen
and now I immediately hooked your pawn
and tried to destabilize you in the
center with the move F6 I think this is
key we will have to wait and see whether
Jeffrey is aware of all these details
all these nuances in the position and
will be able to find the correct path
but if it doesn't he's going to be under
some pressure for the remainder of the
game thank you for that and actually now
that we are still in the Hans game I
just wanted to say that he has really
gave one of the shortest and one of the
longest interviews
certainly here in St Louis yes and both
of them were here and actually I must
say that the social media was booming
yesterday this interview of course I
mean had the most of views people were
discussing saying that Hans is a legend
no matter what he's doing so I mean for
sure that I mean we have this extra
attention on his on him these days right
we cannot ignore it not at all
it was actually funny what Christian was
also saying about the position which was
after Bishop takes D4 Queen takes D4
Queen takes D4 Knight takes D4 and a
number of my games after King E7 players
aware that I was playing for this G5
would play H4 and like an echo of uh one
of the ladies games uh The Rook
oftentimes swung from H3 to C3 which is
actually kind of a a funny
um way of attacking Black's structure
one of the things of course is you look
at this Knight and you say it's really
good one of the things you can do is a
challenge a night on D4 with moves like
Knight B8 and Knight C6 anyway it's uh
an ending that I enjoyed playing as
black we'll see if uh Jeffrey likes it
or not also again I always like uh to
give the respects to the players who are
leading where is Sam savion's game for
just a second is it down or up all the
way down all the way at the very end and
uh let's just check in not too many
moves have been played since we left at
Bishop D7 and Knight B5 and as you said
Alexander londonman starting with the
number one pairing which means he gets
white in his first two rounds yeah he
didn't make a much of an a dent
yesterday against Lavon but okay today's
got a a big fight what's a theoretical
uh evaluation of this very topical
ending as well uh Christian this is we
we are still actually within some
theoretical disputes here at this
particular moment after night to B5 Rook
ac8 was played in a game in 2021 not
long time ago between nihal sarin and
Manuel petrosia so two very promising
Juniors from India and Armenia and uh
generally a very well-known
theoreticians so definitely this one is
one to follow after Knight to B5 Rook to
C8 the position is quite dry so you can
do a lot of things what white is trying
to achieve in the position is at some
point play the move Knight to D6 Force
the trade of the bishopone7 fortnite on
D6 and then just claim the fact that he
has an advantage due to the fact that
you have two Bishops in the positions
two Bishops as well as a pressure on the
B file on the pawn on B7 Rook to B1 is
going to follow followed by the move of
the Knight either to D4 or maybe to D2
and try to put some pressure on B7
that's the key in this position now the
question is will black be in time to put
his own pressure on white sweetness
specifically the pawn on C3 it does feel
like Rook C8 is just a very natural move
it does seem quite dry I don't think any
of the players is going to be able to
put any extra pressure in this game is
going to end up in a draw now what do
you guys think about this one and to be
honest this reminds me of the game
between the ladies almost the one
between Alice Lee
andronova similar structure sure the
pawn on C3 is on B4 in that particular
case but similar type of symmetrical
structure I was going to say it reminded
me of the game between Magnus and Hansen
because of the split pawns uh the pawns
on A4
if I'm allowed I want to go to the game
of Wesley versus uh Christopher you for
just a quick moment uh Wesley so once
again our defending Champion trying to
break through this brick wall that we
call the Russian defense E5 Bishop C7
Queen C2 Knight A6 A3 the players are
getting into a very very topical and
theoretical line Knight C3 F5 huge
decisions that are being made Knight E2
and we've kind of caught up for them
with them I want to say that from a
strategic point of view
White's desire is plainly obvious he
wants to play the move Bishop F4 in
order to trade this dark Square Bishop
so that in the future if those if that
Bishop on C7 didn't exist 95 is an
automatic F2 F3 so it's almost I think
incumbent upon black playing the move F5
F4 just specifically aimed at stopping
the move Bishop F4 now the
other thing is if you do play F4 and if
you do get to play moves like Rook E8
and Bishop H5
watch out that is a really a raging
attack that could easily burn out of
control so Wesley taking some risk here
with white hoping that his younger rival
will not be as familiar with the
position as undoubtedly he is he's such
a well-prepared top professional maybe
you can go back now that you pushed your
Pawn to F4 can you put some pressure on
it for now I don't I just wonder like
basically yes somehow we've been seeing
this back to and through uh back and
forth yes that's it
most probably right well then you might
just take everything yes like how many
how many businesses
you're attacking a lot now if I'm forced
to take yes take maybe take and like
okay okay uh who benefits by all of
these trades what's that Knight doing on
A6 uh yes he's looking for looking for a
future
a better teacher to relocate yes yeah
how about how do you do that I mean this
is not looking good for black yeah
there's also doing not that much
yeah
speaking of the Bishops Bishop on C7 is
kind of in the way as well
uh as we
go through our first hour of the show I
just wanted to invite at first oh big
shout out to our audience thank you so
much for sharing your day with us but we
also like to invite you to join uh the
panel and the discussion I mean we've
made our picks for example we thought uh
who would win the event but if you have
any questions for Anastasia Christian
myself
please feel welcome and I saw uh Ed
Gonzalez was at the opening ceremony
he's our kind of Resident U.S Champion
um trivia he knows incredible amounts of
trivia and here is how do we feel about
the pigs guys well I've got VAR backing
me up I don't know about YouTube but do
you have the one who we promise you to
perform well exactly like you yeah it is
40th birthday uh and in the ladies how
did I do that okay survived and even had
some chances yesterday so I'm very happy
with her play so far welcome to the show
honestly
it's a good start for the boys
the boys
we we have a tournament leaders by the
way just want to emphasize the point for
everybody the audience that might not
have picked up on that uh let's jump to
the ladies and let's see what we've got
well
the big question that we had in the game
between Rochelle and ashrita was that
hey when you went to the move Knight A4
whoops that's not what this is what we
discussed I have to read revive where is
this now I went to the wrong game it's
at the very bottom excuse me and she did
play C4 okay so we saw the move Knight
A4 we did
and I think we kind of stopped here
because we said wait a minute isn't she
walking into this very annoying pin Rook
to C8 are we still in theoretical Waters
yes yes yes yes very deep theoretical
Waters and the truth is
um Rook ac-1 is a move Rook fc1 is the
move Queen to B3 sidestepping this pin
on the C file is a move as well it
doesn't seem like white is putting a lot
of pressure in this position necessarily
but
um yeah it does seem like both of these
players maybe ashrita more than a
Rochelle knows what the theory looks
like in this one because Rochelle
already spent 30 plus minutes off her
clock to get to this position and we're
still in the trenches of uh theory
ashrita on the other hand look at her
very very focused she started off badly
we know she's coming into this event on
a high she actually gained more than 100
rating points
year she was around 2200 2250 for a very
long time quite a few years and she made
a big jump from that 2250 to 2380 close
to 2400 in the last few months beat a
couple of grand Masters on the way as
well with her own coach actually and he
said kachian on on the way as well I've
been analyzing her game she's definitely
been impressing and you can see she's
very very focused and ready to take on
the challenge and potentially try to get
her first championship
wow
I have to say uh you know like I think
as a coach I would be really happy if my
student you know defeated me something's
going uh well there by the way in the
game between Naji and Megan this Scotch
Megan did play the move C6 C5 just not a
allowing that move that you wanted
Anastasia Knight D4 keeping our Queen in
the center she played the move C5
again stop ignite D4 but also and maybe
far more importantly
prepping a retreat any a2a3 is now quite
easy perhaps as well
exactly it's sort of like okay why put
her Queen in front of the bishop on G2
and this construction of Queen on E2 and
Bishop on F1
you got to do something about it you've
got to be able to unwind uh so that you
can develop more freely
whether you start with a move I'm not
saying that this is the great move but
you know you've got to kind of get uh
your your pieces going Queen E4 would
would win a Tempo I think that's pretty
temporary uh thing again let's just drop
in
this was uh I wanted to ask you also
Anastasia these
um these middle games where you and uh
of a majority on one side versus the
majority on the other it's clear it's a
three to one majority uh on the queen
side yes and five against three side yes
if you put the Rook on f8 you're super
happy then you've just castled and
everything you don't have a problem the
fact that the king is a little bit
awkward makes White's life a lot more
happier but in these imbalances of these
Pawn structures did you ever preference
for tonight you like the uh you like the
queen side structures well I think I
prefer the center actually yes sir but
but I think it all depends who spawns
running faster also it's very important
that certain but so far I don't see why
it's sponsored the same positions it
used to be from the beginning of the
game from the start of the game they're
not running anywhere yes at the moment
so easy to find the way how to push them
so easily not to weaken your your
structure at certain points so probably
I would prefer a black structure here
but you're right I mean this king of
Fate bothers me a little bit exactly you
need to
move it to H7 first and then
castle by here and then probably your
background will look really decent
exactly all right we'll keep an eye and
uh of uh the games Christian what is
called your eye a big battle Brewing
here between Ray ruffson and Fabiano
carono big theoretical battle Indian
which seems to have won by uh been won
by Fabiano caruana uh in this Catalan
Knight to E5 Knight to D5 and he was
blissing out his moves up to this point
castle castle B3 Bishop to B7 this is
the first move that Fabiano spent a lot
of time on almost 10 minutes uh on trip
to B7 move and actually not a great
movie it did allow this move Queen to C2
this would have been a very powerful
decision by why he did not play this
move C3 and then Knight to E4 and tried
to Corral this Pawn on a C3 this
weakness in Black's position of course
if you try to hold on to your Pawn after
C takes B3 19 is B3 despite the fact
that you are a pawn up I have control of
so many important squares C5 is one of
them A5 is another one you cannot allow
my knight to go to A5 that's why black
probably has to take control of that
score with the move A5 himself
nevertheless E4 is coming Bishop to D2
Rook to C1 is coming I have a lot of
strategical compensation long-term
compensation due to the fact that I have
so much control over the C and the b
files and especially d square C5 I can
always get a knight to C5 Force the
trade of the bishop for the Knight and
then I'm going to have full control over
the dark Square so a lot of strategical
pitfalls are in this position for black
you don't want to see this from the
black's perspective so after Queen to C2
you probably want to play the move C3
nevertheless after Knight to E4 you have
to continue aggressively with the move
B4 is not that easy especially uh to see
this from afar and then follow it up
with Knight way6 which seems to be
leading to a very complicated battle
nevertheless from a practical
perspective I think Queen to C2 would
have been very powerful he did not play
that he played the move a C4 and let's
take a look at what's happening in that
position right now B3 Bishop to B7 B
takes C4
huge moment if you do take on C4 I'm
just simply going to be able to take
back on C4 it does seem like white is
getting everything he wants yeah that's
terrible I don't think this is playable
you don't want to do this and Fabiano
knows that he is calculating the move
Knight to C3 nevertheless he needs to be
extremely precise check this out going
to E1 Bishop takes G2 King takes G2 and
right now the best move in the position
not an obvious one by any means is
Knight to A4
knightway four exactly now what's the
reason behind that why can't you take on
D4 right take the pawn Knight to F3 due
to the uh absence of any Defenders
except the queen on the Knight on C3
you're lost you have to move the queen I
defend the Knight on E5 I pick up the
Knight on C3 you can resign the game you
cannot take the pawn on D4 so what to do
if you do take on C4 then I can just
simply take it does feel like black has
a weaker structure and maybe he's going
to struggle on less you take the bull by
the horns pick up the pawn on D4 it is
kind of a poison Pawn because I'm
getting a lot of speed and momentum in
the position Bishop to E3 you give me a
check I go King to F1 or even F3 you
have to defend the Knight you still
haven't developed your uh Knight on B8
and Rook on A8 so you still have some
problems to solve as black I don't like
this from a practical perspective if he
sees Knight to A4 on the other hand in
this position
uh Knight to A4
black is actually better because right
now how are you going to defend the pawn
on D4 and without the Knight on C3
stranded as it was if you take on D4
first White is not going to have any
Targets so you have to defend this Pawn
on D4 you have to go Knight to F3 but
then I can start thinking about
potentially accommodating your knight on
E5 maybe this move F6 Knight to D3 I
take on C4 with the tempo as well you
probably have to go to a G4 then I pick
up the pawn and it's going to take some
time to get your Pawn back in the
meantime I will develop my pieces take
control of the B and the D file as well
put a lot of pressure on the pawn on D4
and it doesn't feel like white is
getting any initiative on the king side
or on the important B and C files so
definitely I'm seeing this as better for
black but will Fabiano find the move
Knight to A4 let's wait and see nicely
hidden thank you for that Christian by
the way uh we were we were talking about
the great theoretical battle between
darrish and Sam Shanklin and after the
move Rook on d8 at the CCA that where is
where completely in Sam's prep he's been
blitzing out all of his moves and then
darush went into a 40 that's a 4-0 40
minute thing yes and played a move that
I would have resisted playing because I
really don't understand what the Knight
is doing here on F4 other than
threatening the rather obvious Knight
takes and a bishop takes
but the night has no future on F4 if you
if you sidestep this threat of Knight
takes E6 uh you like where's your next
where where's your next hop maybe not
this thing maybe he wants to make sure
this Knight will go from this really
great position if I I'm not sure if it
works but the funny part was I was
thinking that the night was going back
to D7 anyway but Knight F4 uh came with
a 40 minute thing and okay white is
still
you know he's got the extra half Pawn I
want to say because of the double bonds
but um 40-minute think it's clear that
uh
that wow and
look at Sam like yep I even had that in
my preparation
A5 uh intimating that uh
he wants to play A4 and take control of
the square also
suggesting that Knight takes E6 is going
to be met by
A4
I'm with you I'm with you
exactly well let's just take off a pair
of Rooks just yes I don't know why but
let's do it and it takes so at the end
at the end of the day how many puns just
three right yes
went to this before yeah just three no
I'd say do you want to risk losing
no no no no just
double check A a seven a five uh and if
I do something silly like I make a pass
move a poor a poor pass move let's play
King F2 there there are these ideas from
blacks I perspective of taking over the
C4 Square so that you're actually
eyeballing uh the bishop on E3 the pawn
on C3 so I I think we have to answer the
move A5 by giving our Bishop uh yeah uh
a retreat Square a2a3
well intriguing position also I wanted
to go to linear no no yesterday it's not
an increasing position what's intriguing
is how is Sam Shanklin know all these
things I've been playing like the
groomfield for like the last seven years
of my life and I still don't know as
much Theory as he does and this is the
first tournament that he's playing the
groomfield how does he know so much
theory he couldn't expect his Bishop to
C4 only by Darius right it's all about
the work ethic okay I think coaches
Works 10 hours per day and then the
coaches get lazy that's true you know
it's that lazy Gene you know you got to
get rid of the lazy thing but they're
religions right about salmon and he's
working so hard on chests and clearly
he's one of the best prepared players in
this tournament right I remember just
exactly this kind of conversation we're
having Christian I was working with
Victor korchnoy
and vector's breadth of of openings was
ridiculous and in our preparation don't
ask me why we actually prepared a king's
Gambit
it's a it's okay
it's ridiculous I mean what are you
talking about yes so at a certain moment
we're playing through this King's camp
it
and Victor said well check the oracle
the Oracle was the ecos the encyclopedia
chess openings check the Oracle so I go
and I look all the up all the tables and
there it comes a line a suggestion by
Victor kortuner no right and I said
Victor what do you think about this line
this line this line this line this line
and he looks at it and goes
God
that looks familiar
I said you recommended it ah good idea
nice but uh yeah I don't know what to do
today no you go to table course
I guess guys I think he's preferring a
new chessball course on the grunfeld
he's trying to give Petersville or some
competition
you think that's what it's all about huh
but I had to find a conversation with
King's gumbo it actually was Yandy
bombed he said like I'm planning to play
against
Gambit on the Blitz game it was one of
the games in grantchester and they said
that and he says probably should
consider playing it they said when you
were not a player yet I was already
using this garbage it was not really
right he would love to be nice
of course David bronstein was a big fan
of the king's Gambit and when he was
selected for the Soviet team the
patriarch Michael badvinic World chess
champion said to the team in a in a team
meeting and of course
there will be no Kings gambits in the
team tournament he looked at bronstein
no King's cabin and David was like I
promise A5 okay tell us how theoretical
is the position of dariush and Sam
Shanklin please Christian uh clear the
cobwebs Queen to d8 was the first novel
move all the way back to move 12. okay
and Sam is still blissing out everything
right right DCA Knight to F4 which you
are mentioning is not such a clear move
right we actually would like to direct
that night towards the center via D4
right that's the natural way of doing
things unfortunately once you get it to
D4 I will just simply retreat with the
bishop to E8 and then your Pawn on C5 is
going to be even weaker than it is uh
and that's going to be very easy to
Corral I'm going to go Bishop to f8 and
then pick up the pawn on C5 so he
decides to go for this move Knight to F
or A5 A4 immediately play then let's
take a look at what the engine you see
right the engine is saying that
basically what I have to do is just go
Bishop to E8 followed by Bishop to S8
and at some point this Pawn on C5 is
going to drop so very interesting uh
battle going on in this one but I have
to say I'm mightily impressed with the
way Sam Shanklin treats his openings he
just simply knows them by heart now
let's take a look at what's happening
between Hans and Jeffrey Jeffrey did
decide against that move A6 which I
thought it's practically uh inferior to
what he did A6 Knight takes C6 take on
B5 and now this move Knight to D4 back
followed by B4 you're going to have some
problems with the bishopone C5
he took on D4 Bishop takes D4 and not
Bishop takes D4 because of the end game
that we were discussing and now with H4
stopping you from going G5 Rook to H3
Bishop to D3 it feels good for white so
you're not going to do that he played
the move Castle so he's doing the best
he can to equalize the position
maybe we're going to see B4 on the board
and then we're going to go into that end
game but what I'm going to try to do as
black is immediately hint to the fact
that I need to weaken your Pawn
structure I cannot allow your Pawn
structure to stay as it is it's just
simply too powerful and it's too
controlling for my position for my taste
if he goes F6 in that particular case I
think he will be able to equalize
nevertheless we have a big fight ahead
of ourselves thank you Christian and
just taking quick look at Lavon versus
Lanier a very slow play but intriguing
intriguing uh line that Levon has played
is this has done this Rook lift and
sometimes you you know you kind of see
um what Victor coach and I would say
simple chess you know it's so simple you
just bring your Rook to E1 you threaten
Knight takes F7 you play moves like Rook
F3 and before you know it you have an
initiative and it just kind of builds
and builds uh we'll keep an eye on this
yeah
yeah hooker three yes it looks looks
quite promising it does doesn't it uh
Anastasia maybe but you have something
uh special uh our friends from cubatique
across the street yes so we have skip
Boutique shop and I invite everyone to
visit it today we have this nice chess
club wallow and we have with different
colors and available now in the shop
it's athletic style Polo and has a
variety of colors and it's available for
both men's and women's size sizing
and also the West comes with it look at
it looks nice I like this green one
actually I like the logo of the club I
like the SLC uh I and I think uh we
ripped off the
fireman's Association they have these
beautiful the St Louis firemen they have
this and we said hey that's a really
good idea let's use the same uh script
for our logo very very nice yes we're
going to take our first bait and we're
going to see everybody on the other side
of the break
thank you
you may have heard about St Louis's
world-class Museums Art History Science
even magic
you may not know we have an entire
Museum dedicated to play with a 10 story
slide and a ferris wheel on top
don't let all this family fun Slide by
you
[Music]
whose kids it is Saint Lou is always
exploring anybody
[Music]
[Music]
.com
[Music]
we're the Corey family Welcome to our
show
[Music]
you guys
[Music]
St Louis University celebrating its
200th anniversary offering world-class
education in the heart of St Louis SLU
attracts students and professors from
around the globe
in 2015 slew partnered with the St Louis
chess club to start a top-tiered
Collegiate chess team on the very first
year of the team's Inception SLU
obtained second best university of the
Pan-American Intercollegiate chess
championships
higher purpose greater good St Louis
University
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to round two of us
championships and here we have the
current standings
is leading together with Jennifer you
Ellis Lee and Megan Lee lots of people
with 50 and in the open standings and in
the open standings we have a tie for the
first place Sam Savion and Hansen even
both of them have one point and then one
clue
50 including this group of gangsters
that have the Wesley Lanier Jeffrey Sam
Ray and it goes on what a competition we
have if we as we see a view of the
playing Hall and I wanted to say that
earlier in one of these views I I
inspired one of the media for ESPN ESPN
has joined uh coverage of the US
championships so welcome to them in pet
San we can see same seven yes walking at
the moment and it looks different
actually this plane when you compare it
to a single cup where we had only five
boards now it's full of people and no
more couches no more you know
armchairs easy resting places yeah we
got a full a full house with the 28
players six players and the Arbiters uh
turning to as we were coming on break I
was very curious to see what Christopher
uh was going to do about Wesley's
implied positional threat of Bishop F4
what he did is he said you know what go
ahead you go ahead and play your Bishop
F4 and I'll be very happy to double your
pawns with the move Bishop takes F3 and
Wesley said okay go ahead and double my
pawns but let me make sure that my my
knight is a safe League close to my king
so that after Bishop takes F3 G takes F3
I'm ready to pounce in case that night
moves on the F5 pawn and Christopher
said okay well now
or let's go back and Wesley said okay uh
just a second I think we actually had a
92 again yeah and a bishop H5 oh my gosh
and a knight G3 and a bishop G6 so
um we saw this uh kind of easy draw for
Wesley with the black pieces I don't
against a low rated player I don't think
he's so is going to be quite so uh
generous with a draw offer by making the
draw with the white pieces in fact he
did make an alternative he played the
move B2 before you were right yes sir
just you mentioned it of course the
Wesley will not to make another door so
easily not so easily uh the move B2B uh
by the way uh very important move in in
the sense of defending the pawn on C5
well isn't the part not already defended
well yes it is but now that the pawn is
reinforced by the B4 pawn it does make
the move Knight E5 permissible in other
words if we started with the move Knight
E5 we should be uh excuse me that's a
mouselet we should be aware that that is
upon sacrifice Bishop takes Pawn takes
this Knight on A6 which is doing nothing
suddenly is doing a lot wake up wake up
exactly so b2b4 a kind of a preface for
that and also just
to turn the ball over to Chris
Christopher and say well what do you
want to do most likely something like
Rook a E8 but yes we've already talked
about it this night as a offsides on the
A6 square and he'll look to solve those
problems Christian as we resume our
coverage what game of the country right
there's a lot of them that are getting
quite interesting and we were discussing
at the beginning of the show about this
game between Levon and Roni and the
birthday boy and Lanier Dominguez and I
think you guys were mentioning something
along the lines of Queen to B3 try to go
for these pawns and it was always the
refutation of long Castle right long
Castle defending on B7 and defending on
D5 well Levon decided that much more
importantly he needs to finish his
development Bishop to D2 he started off
quite nicely Bishop to D6 and now Rook
to E3 not only that you want to patrol
the third rank Rook to F3 Rook to H3
Rook to G3 put some pressure especially
on this Pawn on F7 because you also have
the Knight attacking that point in
Black's position but also to get this
Rook to E1 and double up on the only
open file in the position and after that
you get to have all sorts of ideas of
Knight takes F7 softening up the defense
of the Knight on E6 so a lot of
um Ambitions by white presented with
this move Rook to E3 so let's take a
look at what happened the engine is
saying short Castle why short Castle we
will understand in just a second he
decided to go long Castle Lanier in the
game the problem is after Rook to E1
Rook to E8 let's say Rook to F3
Queen to H5 now the best move with the
position in this position is to go
actually H3
and we will compare this position with a
long castle with the position exactly
the same position but with the King on
G8 and short Castle now let's take a
look at that one
in this position with the King on G8
after Rook to F3 Queen to H5 H3 I have
this beautiful move Knight takes D4 if
you take Queen takes D4 Rook takes E5
why is this position much better for
black than with the castle uh with the
king castle long well if you Castle long
and you get the same position the
problem is when you take on D4 I take
back you take on E5
and I take only seven right there's no
Checkmate coming on E1 you can exchange
sure I restore the material balance not
only that but I also have quintway
coming followed by Queen takes B7 I also
have this Rook patrolling on the third
rank this queen has to stay to the
defense of the Pawn on F7 so it does
feel from an objective point of view as
well as from a visual point of view that
White's position is just much better
yeah big difference Queen to E5 right
now maybe that's okay yeah yeah yeah you
can but are you even checkmating me if I
go for the pawn maybe I don't think I
have to go for the pawn
oh sorry you're taking the Beach Boys
maybe rookie three or even King to F1
well maybe you can go with one yes
sidestepping both Queen to H2
immediately uh Queen to H2 and queen
takes C1 you cannot go Rook to E8
because of Rook to E3 yeah that's game
over on the spot so if you try to invade
with Queen twitch to well sure but
you're still a couple of tempies away
from creating some big problems for my
king so in the meantime I can go Rook to
F7 I'm threatening Checkmate be very
careful you can give me a check I go out
you can give me another check I go up
okay there's no more checks you are very
brief well I'm giving you Checkmate yes
I am brave I understand but your queen
is out of uh out of the game and I'm
also giving you a Checkmate there's no
way to defend against Checkmate you can
go Rook to E7 but that's going to allow
me to exchange a lot of pieces I'm just
going to be in a much better situation
winning position for white at this point
so
definitely things are starting to look
tense for black I'm not seeing the path
towards equality for Lanier and I think
he's starting to realize that none of
the Tactical motifs that he had with the
King on G8 castled on the other side
exist with a king on C8 and that might
be a problem and also a problem is at a
certain moment I I saw that he took like
a 20 minute Think Tank on Long Castle
almost 40 years on Long Castle stand
corrected yes uh what's a what are the
clocks now I mean he's he should be
thinking rapidly or accelerating rapidly
towards those time uh trouble moments 47
minutes yes
to an hour and two minutes
yeah so it's like almost half time like
two times yes yes yes no no an hour and
two minutes
yeah yeah so this one is yeah as well
yes okay and Bishop takes E5 he said
okay I don't want to live with these
Rook F3 Knight F7 ideas I've just got to
eliminate that night so Rook Bishop
takes E5 Rook takes E5 and we'll have
that imbalance of
what's better than [ __ ] the bishop
in Blitz Games
we prefer at night exactly yeah
um
no it's really nice to see them playing
and fighting I mean like really their
friends in life but when they when it
comes to chess they really would like to
play normal game and simply learn from
each other I really appreciate this
attitude
you can see it it was always very
difficult for me to develop that
attitude when I was playing a friend I
didn't want to play with friends
competitively and beat them or be beaten
by them either but later I realized that
that was the correct attitude which was
just it's Sport and you play for sport I
want to turn our attention to a game
between our two leaders Alice uh Lee and
begum for just a moment because there
was a moment here that it was a little
bit mystified by Alice's decision right
here Alice made a move that most grand
Masters would a shoe and that is Bishop
F1 she retreated and we understand why
she retreated the bishop is actually not
serving a great purpose on the Square C4
it's on an open file so maybe it
shouldn't be on C4 there's an argument
to be made for the move Bishop B3
but also the idea is that the bishop is
in the way of the night so the Knight
could hop nicely to the V6 square and uh
invade Black's Camp so she chose the
move Bishop F1 I think most grand
Masters would have chosen the square E2
well the king maybe yes yes leave the
king and maybe just protect the rook and
who knows maybe this Knight moves and
the bishop goes here she played Bishop
to F1 but she did it with the idea of
the game position and it was a rather
remarkable idea if you ask me she got to
this position probably when she played
the move Bishop F1 and it reminds I
could now play the move Rook C1
pinning the Knight to The Rook if the if
the if the bishop had been on E2 yes
then begum could play Knight takes D4
wow wow
you're asking me like what is the
difference so I mean it takes time to
understand you I was trying to scope it
out myself like why did she choose that
square F1 over E2 and the game justifies
her decision now uh can she make
something out of her more active pieces
if you kind of just look begum's pieces
are a little bit they're misplaced
they're not that great this bishop on B2
may be better than its counterpart this
Rook is actually really
um awkward I don't know if I was a
threat already or not maybe B5 is a
threat because uh things are getting
jammed up here and uh again uh begum
fantastic first board leader of the US
uh women's Olympic team up against 12
year old Alice Lee and Alice Lee is
saying wait a minute I can throw some
patties actually you know we haven't we
had this saying I don't know if you had
this one if you play with somebody who's
much younger you have to go to the
ending right yes exactly exactly
it seems not the case here right so far
Alice is doing really well that was the
thing you kind of hit the nail right on
the head for me as well so Junior
players you just
and grind them down and beat them up
because all they do is focus on the
openings yeah
then there was this young punk kid the
Magnus Carlson yes this young fun kid
you know at 13 years old he'd love to
play the ending I mean that was his
Forte and it was like wait a minute this
kid is really really good
but I like Alice's uh position I mean
maybe she'll be thinking about
fianchetto in the near future G3 Bishop
G2 just improving the bishop but I also
like what you said Anastasia B5 uh that
knights in the pin whenever you have a
pen piece so perhaps what black has to
do is get rid of that Knight on B6 it's
a very uncomfortable night right yes so
let's try to exchange some pieces go
Knight D5 Knight D5
okay and let's see what we can do about
that
because just a few moves uh away from
exchanging everything
and if you get all of those trades in
nicely in a nice way and the problem is
I don't
does G3 work yeah I was just asking the
same quiz okay so let's go Knight takes
D4 I'm curious if Knight takes D4 Works
964 you take on C7 Knight to F3
this might just simply work oh yes
D1 you take on E7 but I go Bishop C6
right
I'm Not Afraid wait a second
you should be afraid I'm afraid I'm
afraid maybe it sounds like maybe five
hours even no no 91 okay no like King H3
Rook F1 right I mean it doesn't
yeah but I have to do something maybe
yes
sometimes
that is true so maybe I have to respond
with a great move of my own don't do it
yes I thought about it
okay so we're still in there throwing
the patties I don't know for how long
yes Bishop E2 that doesn't work because
of Rook G1 no interesting complicated
but if we go back just to this moment
and I appreciate what you were saying
there that was a nice trick that you
laid out but Bishop takes D4 or right
inviting any Rook traits I'm still
angling I think Alice still has some
pulling you do have that Bishop to G2
very annoying move I have to I have to
say so if you if you do end up allowing
me something I mean I feel like I got a
little pull here uh and what if I go
Bishop C6 here instead of no even even
towards the end
Bishop C6 how is this end game after I
would assume you go Bishop G2 Rook D6
quite an annoying tickle I have to say
sorry to d8 and whenever you take on C6
my plan was to go Rook C8 okay he
continues Bishop B5 I'm just trying yeah
yeah yes he's fighting with us
yeah he's fighting with us no no no no
no I don't like it no I think what you
did was was good look the D6 Bishop to
E5 but perhaps Rook d8 is actually
better yes
it it I I brought this whole point up
because of this strange move Bishop F1
and I was trying to understand where
Alice was coming from and it was like
Wow hey look that's that's pretty
impressive she's making a Fate by the
way oh
king of fight really not afraid of B5
interesting let's check let's go okay
she's defending the bishop so she's
thinking in case of B5 Knight takes
Rook takes now again the bishop is
defended that's the key so that after
Knight F3 takes and she's hoping to turn
the tables then this pin means that
Bishop takes B5 oops excuse me that was
supposed to be Bishop takes B5 is on tap
okay so I can I can uh you can leave me
that
makes it makes a lot of sense to me too
and maybe I'll just go back to the
standby plan of G3 and Bishop G2 for the
moment yeah and once again nine days
before I guess is the position and we'll
just go for that whole sequence what is
this position yeah that is the question
Maybe
maybe black in this case uh The Rook a
moment ago The Rook was a little bit
vulnerable there's Bishop takes A6 oh
excuse me I didn't nothing wrong I
definitely didn't intend to blunder upon
good morning St Louis
just really it's really nice how you can
see all these consequences especially
probably that white has more active
pieces so these variations are working
pretty well still some pressure for
white absolutely yes exactly let's just
check in on another of our tournament
leaders Jennifer you again we have these
isolated Queen pump positions
um
h2h3 still uh Jennifer's saying I always
like these light squared Bishops by the
way in these positions I kind of rely
upon them to capture the isolani uh
Jennifer's not uh unhappy about the
trade she invites it once more with
move Knight B3 eyeballing this Pawn on
D5
if I were in black shoes I would just
probably capture and step back with the
bishop maybe something like this and I
would my instinct is The Game's fairly
balanced especially is this bishop isn't
uh doing anything uh consequences not on
F4 or G5 should be even and she's done
it Knight takes
F3 check on the board Again Jennifer
starts one and O she's got to go 13-0 if
she's has any hopes for the Bobby Fisher
prize of 64. she still has somehow still
has some hopes uh let's jump into Arena
crushes game because that was the
imbalance the the two Bishops for white
versus the Central Pawn duo in the
middle of of the board for Sabina again
it's an imbalance
um
uh we're we're going to wait for the
players to define the position after the
pawn moves forward either E4 or D4 or
maybe better not to happen
at all and what do you have for us uh
Christian there was a big moment in this
game between Rochelle and ashrita check
this out so I think we left it somewhere
around Rook to C8 right F3 was the move
uh that Rochelle decided to go for
Knight to C3 destabilized the Knight on
e4 the Knight on e4 is a very unpleasant
piece right he's right in the center
ready to jump to C3 ready to support
potentially the other night to jump to
C3 very unpleasant piece to deal with
that's why you should play the move F3
Knight C3 Bishop to D3 and G6 and after
the move Bishop to D2 which was played
in the game I'm not 100 sure by the way
how accurate that movie is because it
does allow this simple D takes C4 and
I'm not 100 sure why shrita decided
against this because this is quite a
straightforward calculation if you take
on C3 I take on D3 resignation time of
course take on data I take on C3 I'm a p
sub you cannot do that so you have to
take on G6 H stage G6 Bishop takes C3
but after B5 it does feel like this one
is quite easy to assess I'm threatening
something I'm threatening to go Rook to
E8 and keep full control of your break
with E6 so you have to play six
immediately right but at 36 I just
simply take on C3
it's not so simple
C3 you take on C3 I take on E6 there's
no more Queen on C2 attacking the pawn
on G6 so if you take on C6 on E6 you I
take on E6 I'm one Pawn up but my king
is actually safe the King on G8 is
perfectly safe there's not enough
um material on the board to actually
create any problems against my king on
G8 I'm going to go Queen to F6 get the
queen around the king and then my
majority on the queen side is going to
be decisive you cannot allow that so so
almost for me but okay like when
Christian says this is the big this is
the big variation it isn't D7 what if
you take on D7 right this is what I
think she missed check this out B4 oh no
I'm just simply defending mine
sure yeah
and she has to understand that this
position despite the fact that you are
in exchange down in exchange for a pawn
these two pawns are extremely powerful
foreign actually not only do they give
you full compensation you're much better
with black pieces right now very
intriguing variation difficult to see
this move before this was the key right
she did not see that and she played the
move Knight to B5 instead of D takes C4
after Queen takes A4 Knight takes D4
Queen takes A7 once again everything
forced that Queen was attacked by the
bishop on D7 Why not pick up a pawn at
the same time Target the Knight on D4
this is what we have right now and it
does feel like after d takes E4 Queen
takes D4 if you take on D3 I'm just
simply picking that up Pawn up for white
not bad not bad I think white is just
doing much better at this point black
does have this intriguing move Bishop to
E6 and maybe this gives him a her
um enough compensation in this game for
the pawn take on d8 take on d8 take on
C4 take on C4 you do have a lot of
active pieces and I don't think white is
going to be able to claim an advantage
and this one despite the extra Pawn so
quite a big moment in that one she did
not see that variation ending with a B4
and right now she most likely will have
to defend a slightly weaker position
I just want to bring this back down
about 12 notches here
it was not a simple variation simply
before giving away the
way to take the night with check and
then you're in exchange down but you've
got these two fast pawns just before so
easy yes yes it proves that we're still
human beings you know I mean it's not
possible to see it too so quickly
catching my breath through a lot of
those variations yeah but it looked nice
I mean the variations were really
beautiful yes they were oh and by the
way
Knight C6 was her choice not the D5 take
C4 I don't know how to feel about that
because I can just simply go Queen to E3
Queen E3 makes sense the queen is under
attack they protect the pawn
uh you get your queen out of Hawk you're
upon up where's the compensation with
two Bishops uh as well uh looks like
Rochelle through all of the
I want to say something complications
through all the topsy-turvy somehow has
come out on top and this and uh enjoys
uh at the end waiting yeah I'm not sure
also like I started
but never mind what variations did what
did I missed no no I mean at six Queen
D5 was so yeah
but it doesn't matter yes all this see
all these ghosts right so let's go back
let's keep going let's I think that's an
important variation actually Knight
takes C5 I take on C4 you go
I'll give you a check so he wants to
play Bishop B6 no I want to go exactly
yes
but if Queen is 27 Rook F7 and I'm not
I'm still not sure whether you have the
killing all the business squares are
protected
oh man it's just something but what if
you go Queen E2
that's a tickle rookie C8 and now Queen
E7
yeah that might be problematic sweet yes
but it felt there that like black was
hanging on by a thread and was relying
upon tactics to save her uh position uh
let's just take a quick look we haven't
dropped in on Sophie and Talia for some
time well we saw this uh slow laborious
but castling by hand the king telia's
king is now safe she's ready to play the
move Rook C8 and I think she can face
the future with confidence as long as
she doesn't lose this pawn and you force
him out uh that game uh this was our
Scotch uh game uh White has nicely put
her Bishop on C3 but she still needs to
address a very
crucial
Development question how are you going
to get your Bishop on F1 in the game you
might want to play moves like G3 and
Bishop H3 but don't forget the C4 Pawn
is also hanging
let's see Jennifer
yes we just saw this they did in fact go
into that variation that we expected
looks balanced Anna and Tata yes I was
just about to say how is my people
it looks like a balanced position I
would imagine after Queen takes C4 uh
What uh nc5 yeah what we call Modern
chess play Rook f8 to C8 just like Sam
shankly yes you know you prepare a C5
you don't play Rook ac8 you play Rook F
C8 what was the problem right yeah but
now we know yeah after the game yeah
and uh over to you Christian and what's
happening in the in the open section
well I'm looking at this game of uh Hans
uh against Jeffrey and after Bishop
takes C5 Castle Bishop takes C5 was
played not the move B4 that we were
discussing as well because of Bishop
takes D4 and F6 that might be
problematic he took on C5 5 Knight takes
C5 the engine is saying that Queen takes
E5 was better because you want to keep
the Knight on D7 a bit more passive but
also with a lot more potential because
right now after F6 I'm going to have a
lot of pressure on E5 and it's all about
the square E5 this Pawn on E5 because
the pawn on E5 is also supporting the
Knight to jump to D6 and this is
precisely the problem that black has
right now after Knight takes C5 Queen to
D4 Queen to D4 defending the pawn on
Beto and getting ready to jump with the
Knight to D6 for example if you go
Bishop D7 I go Knight D6 there's no
Queen takes P2 so black Jeffrey song
that is has to do something and he has
to do it quickly I think still F6 is
probably the best move in the position
and then we will have to wait and see
because we know what white is going to
do white is most likely going to Castle
long Bishop to E2 and try to at some
point displays the Knight on C5 and
enter a superior end game
black on the other hand will try to put
a lot of pressure on the pawn on E5
these are the two plans these are the
two emerging plans for both sides but
it's still going to be a very
complicated middle game very very
intriguing game between these young
players and we do see a move I do think
we have F6 on the board yep F7 F6 as you
prescribed uh just played by Jeffrey it
it strikes me that this position
a lot of things hang on a single Tempo I
mean
if it was black to move and he could get
in to move F6 takes E5 and if that were
to re choir uh Queen takes E5 then a
move like Knight E4 and suddenly you
know black might have an initiative so
everything revolves uh around this you
know like a very precise set of moves
will you be able to stabilize the
position yes why that's exactly because
if you do and if you don't lose the pawn
on E5 I'm going to have that Knight on
D6 landing and that's going to be a very
powerful night very controlling night
speaking of can we stabilize the
position just again I'll take a look at
our defending Champion Wesley so up
against Christopher you when we left it
we actually left it just after the move
b2b4 so you might think that not not too
much has taken place but in fact with
this last move Knight E2
black is actually facing
um he's on the horns of a dilemma I want
to put it like that uh Knight E5 is
basically a positional winning threat
let's say we play a move like Knight B8
which is probably a very bad move
suddenly bang knight E5 Bishop takes now
you start to see some very bad things
happening this bishop is actually
playing on a really important role the
Knight is coming to either F4 D4
this night which is the pride in Black's
position is in danger of being expelled
F2 F3 just kicks you right out so you're
almost like we're going to go back for a
moment to Christopher's previous uh play
you're almost going to find yourself
compelled to get rid of that night
before it lands on the F4 square and you
could end up in a position
where it's like two Knights versus two
Bishops once again maybe F2 F3 is uh
yeah I have to maybe yeah
make allowance for this move F3 by
giving my knight a square defending uh
so I see this as a fight with all the
pieces on the board I love this kinds of
uh fights and this move uh Knight E2
really puts the pressure on Christopher
to find an exact sequence to stay in the
game
um am I over am I overselling this but
it does feel good for
Wesley Christian it definitely does but
there's also some problems in Wesley's
position specifically his time but just
to take you back one second because I
just spotted a very cool line in this
game of Hans versus Jeffrey check this
out after F6 if you play the natural
Castle this feels like a very natural
move right yes the problem is that I
take only five I take only five I go
Bishop D7 you go Knight D6 this is a
very normal sequence and now I have this
brilliant move Rook to F2 check this
move out you cannot take yes because
right Knight to B3 that's a discovery
check I'm picking up the queen and
that's pretty much over I mean you're
going to have to uh maybe not over but
you're going to have to defend black is
definitely better borderline winning so
you cannot take on F2 probably you have
to go something along the lines of B4
and once again it looks like black is in
trouble but I don't care about the
Knight I'm actually going to go Bishop
to A4 and that's why it's important to
start with Bishop D7 and then Rook F2
not leave the Knight on a B5 quite a
brilliant maneuver by a black that's why
the best movie in the position right now
is to just wait
play the move Bishop to E2 hint at the
fact that maybe you will go short castle
at times and now unfortunately for back
there's there's no more Rook to F2
because I just simply take with the king
or with the queen and the queen is
protected on F2 just uh details in the
position that matters for the assessment
of the position and let's wait and see
whether Hans and Jeffrey will understand
all these nuances hands down to his last
37 minutes Jeffrey with 45 minutes on
the clock I like that Bishop D7 Rook F2
really really really nice that that
that's deep the big uh theoretical deal
between darush and as Sam Shanklin is
kind of settled down some dust after A5
A4 Bishop went back to EA more or less
as expected where Sam is hinting at the
right night to D7 and Bishop to f fate
again he's sort of like challenging
white please go ahead and bring your
faithfulness yeah follow up with your
threat of taking on the E6 there he said
no I'm happy trading off the bishop and
making it still that awkward if you will
to capture this Pawn on C5 maybe on a
good day the bishop could relocate a
long long time ago Christian said you
know what upon on B7 is the weakness and
Rook B1 could Target the pawn this is
our current position and it feels like
well
Sam has still some issues he's got to
solve but look at the time difference
I'm sure Sam has 16 years 60 Minutes for
darush 60 degrees 16 years how many
moves 20 more moves
what's happened to your student no it's
not your I think it's just that is yeah
you take no responsibility for this
family I don't think he's uh his student
anymore I think Darius graduated yes but
there are no former students right if he
was a student
well that's a student though yes the
question is how do you defend that pawn
on C5 if I just simply go King F6 follow
it by
Knight to E5 King F6 Knight to E5
wow that's if you do lose the pawn on C5
you have to be careful because you might
actually be worse so maybe a four would
have to play I think you have to go F4
yeah to prevent this Knight E5 looks
really strong uh the other I I was so
anxious to get in Rook B1 but in this
case I think you're you're happy to
trade we trade but I trade for your
opponent A4 actually ah then that a pawn
might become very dangerous for you
absolutely King F6 Anastasia
well I I I'm 100
approving of f4 to stop 95 Okay
Christian
um what to say here I mean maybe we play
if I've well I mean black to move but I
do think Rook B1 and Bishop C2 is
can well I'm not not 100 sure you really
want to do this I'm not sure also yeah
the king might be exposed to uh maybe
it's too much energy five square I don't
want to give up this device
this is wrong for too many points so you
can't play E5 but what we're boy here
came back to E7
not 100 sure what the what the great
follow-up here is
I mean we have to threaten the spawn
somehow on C5 but but I don't see the
way actually your plan was 97 before was
not maybe working because of some 96 or
Bishop B6 I don't remember exactly but I
mean here it's not easy to put the
Knight on D7 unless you want to play
Knight b897 no something like this looks
a bit artificial I'm not a fan
let's keep an eye on that one and let's
go to the game of Fabiano because uh
when we left it Christian had talked
about this move Knight C3 which was
found by the way Bishop takes G2 King
Chase G2 and I think here in 194 years
yes
what a move Knight A4 that would have
been something special yeah instead he
took Knight F3 and the players have
reached
this peculiar position Queen B1
uh first thoughts are that well White's
enjoying a better structure it's all
about the same phone yes and so many
cattle lands that I've witnessed over
the years
uh if black somehow manages to get in
the move C7 C5 and liquidate and
equalize perfect he doesn't get in C5
yes big weakness is staring at uh on C7
uh we'll keep an eye on this one and I'm
just going to go to a Wonder Liang this
is the elshon game remember that sites
up with A4 turned into a brayer
and after Knight A4 ooh
laughs
my first impression after all of these
Soviet championships from the 1970s is
black is better
which is like really amazing
these big lines uh these uh huge games
that I remember so well oh boy and black
at the moment
is uh very nicely he has two Bishops but
more importantly there's an issue here
now elshon will have seen all of what
has occurred doubtlessly he is he's
putting his uh
bets if you will on this move night
before uh willingly uh trading the pawn
on e4 to getting a night on a D5 in the
near future so for example if you play
Tags I'm not saying for example yes
exactly good for you
you're right
and uh
so uh I'd like to preface my next
comments by saying that Christian has a
very honorable guest in the studio a
recent World in dot d Christian over to
you absolutely and actually I'm going to
give it to you Yasser because you guys
are very good bodies and I want you to
get all your questions in uh I don't
want you to miss any one of them so
hit Eugene with someone first of all
Eugenio Welcome to our studio so nice to
have you here how are you liking St
Louis
yeah I'm very happy to be here this is
my first time and I'm glad I made it
here because uh it's incredible uh City
you know and it very much deserves the
the name that it is the
how do you call this the chess city of
the world yeah nice well the Chastity of
the world likes to invite uh you a chess
Legend to the city I've been singing
your praises and telling the people of a
time we shared in Hyde Park in London
where you sang For Me Frank Sinatra's My
Way
and you absolutely stunned me uh you're
you're a great singer uh Eugene as well
as a great chess player
well I I tried to be but uh usually I
use my singing so that when I exercise
usually I exercise one hour in the
morning and one hour in the half late in
the afternoon by walking uh it helps me
uh
uh not minding the time walking when I'm
you know uh
singing music Sometimes some people
thought that I was kind of crazy because
but they didn't know that I was just
singing to you know to uh to pass a time
yes you need Yasser to be walking next I
appreciated it very much and again uh
wonderful to have you in studio
Anastasia and Christian would like to
ask you also questions about your career
and uh Anastasia yeah you you played so
many chess Olympics if we are not
mistaken it's 22 Olympics I mean what a
record uh maybe you can remember which
Olympiad was the very special for you
which one of them you remember the most
well I think those games I played
especially against the grand Masters in
1974 when I got my Grandmaster
title in this Olympiad and of course
those games when we made our best finish
in
in outside of the 74 Olympia that was in
1988
in Thessaloniki Greece wherein we I
think we placed seventh overall so that
was a great achievement for the
Philippines and then of course the one
the last Olympiad I played in 2016
because
I made I was surprised myself of my
performance and
and I think I got the bronze medal on
the third board scoring nine wins you
know and two draws so uh I was surprised
myself that's why after that I did not
play anymore in in future Olympia
because I don't think I can duplicate
Eugene in your uh induction uh Speech
you mentioned Wesley so and your
relationship with him as well and he
always talks highly of you tell us a bit
about your relationship with one of the
United States best players right now
Wesley so yeah we have very good
relationship with uh with with Wesley
because
I was very much impressed with him you
know when he was still young and uh I in
some of my or in one of my interviews I
said that Wesley is a rare find you know
and we have to give all the support he
needed and I was not wrong because I saw
that he could promote or develop his
chest skill on his own without uh
seconds I noticed that that on his own
he is able to improve his chest
knowledge somehow
typical of Bobby Fisher was that the
biggest Factor when you tried to assess
his potential the fact that he was so
well versed in working on his own and
coming up with ideas on his own yeah
let's uh uh that's part of the
consideration you know at a young age I
seldom see young players able to improve
by themselves normally you have somebody
to assist you so that means that on his
own by studying alone he can improve
himself and the thing is he like very
much to study chess you know he loved
chess very much so very important and
you also supported his move from the
Philippines to the United States you
felt like this would open a lot of doors
for him do you feel the same way right
now yes yes of course
it's important that what your heart or
your mind wish for you to do then you do
it you know anyway among Filipinos uh we
we consider still uh
Wesley as our countrymen as a Filipino
just the same and uh
we wish him although he is representing
the United States that's good because he
is being well supported also here in the
U.S so as much as Americans would wish
him success
same same also with us Filipinos Eugene
thank you very much for joining the show
and congratulations once again on your
career and your induction
congratulations thank you very much for
inviting me here lovely to see you thank
you very much in the meanwhile we do
have a draw in the game between
Alexander Linderman and Sam uh savian
Sam being one of our tournament
co-leaders coming into this round the
final position by the way is kind of
like shall we say about his drought is
as it can be uh Bishops of opposite
color uh the game of Wesley by the way
really really heating up as the move
Knight E5 as prescribed as landed on the
board just a second we this is where we
left it 87.95 before
life should do something yeah that you
kind of got to do but now he's got to
start uh thinking like hmm
what's going on along this diagonal can
I play the move F2 F3 and uh possibly uh
snag some material here can we just have
a quick look see F3 if I remove the
knife yeah just let's as they say
see the
the obvious for a moment now is there
some crazy way that the queen could end
up on E3
this is a weird I I I'm on a I'm going
down a rabbit for example
okay first uh but this just simply
okay and if we first give a check Queen
is free okay so is it any difference
let's find out Queen e33 and after King
get one now if you take on the street I
think it's not a big deal unfortunately
there is
yes
okay you don't see anything uh forcing
and again this is the way I've always uh
calculated and thought I I really really
like looking at the most forcing moves
first to my mind F2 F3 is a very forcing
move and then you know I go down the
whole thing and I say okay uh that's
winning and maybe I I have to play
different moves Bishop takes E5 uh the
game of Wesley and Christopher uh really
feels like well Wesley's beginning to
take over is is that the case uh
Christian let's take a look at that one
I was looking at the completely
different one oh it is taking over but
it's not as clear Rook 1036 seems to oh
takes G6 yes
F3 that was a big problem and you guys
mentioned this right after htx G6 you
have to drop back you lose the pawn on
G6 that's problematic but you have to
take back with the rook and seek some
sort of compensation against the white
king nevertheless it still feels like
white is definitely on top of the remove
such as Knight to C3 and it makes a lot
of sense right you want to set up this
pin you want to take only four black has
to find very very precise moves to even
hope for some sort of compensation on
the king side Queen to H4 is the only
move not Queen to G5 directly attacking
the Checkmate after F3 you can actually
resign wow I'm defending the pawn on G2
with my queen you take on C3 I take on
G6 you don't have a way to open up the
bishop anymore because F3 for uh black
doesn't work anymore obviously because
there's a Pawn on F3 so you're in
trouble you have to go Queen to H4 but
Queen to H4 I can go F3 I can take on e4
I can take with the bishop on e4 as well
sure things can get messy nevertheless
it does feel like these are type of
positions that Wesley just simply finds
the best moves and usually converts so
I'm quite worried I have to say for uh
Christopher in this one but check this
out elshon versus a wonder what's
happening in this one Queen takes B5
this was uh the position and I was
thinking about Bishop to d8 tried to
Target The Pawn on A5 you're not in time
I'm going to go 95 take take sure you
take my Pawn but after take take massive
simplifications and now I just simply
pick up the D6 Pawn I'm a pawn up I have
two passers and you have no compensation
this is completely winning devastating
position for black so he played the move
Bishop takes F3 G takes F3 Rook fb8 but
that's a lot of parts
Queen C4 is on the board Queen C4 is on
the board great move Queen D5 Queen to
C4 keep the square D5 uh available for
the night shirt there are still some
complications because maybe Queen D7
you're hinting at the fact that you
might take on H3 but even if you take on
H3 right you can take these pawns on
this side I'm going to promote one of uh
the a or the B Pawn I mean you're in
trouble after B4 right and if you think
I have a feeling I might be able to
exchange the Queens right
Queen H6 Knight to F5 this almost forces
the trade you still have Queen to D2 but
it's not looking good I can preface that
with the move Rook to D1 Knight to F5 is
coming we're exchanging the Queens
you're in trouble it feels like a
special have gone wrong really bad
I mean I have a couple of Pawns ready
for promotion this one is not looking
good for a wonder that would be a big
bounce back victory for the newcomer to
the U.S championship foreign
I actually do think it's not his debut I
actually think he did play once he did
play another one yes yeah you're right
for the US Open uh champion and he knows
he's coming into this tournament with a
big Target on his own oh he's got that
low rating and everybody says well I'm
not going to get points from Sam and I'm
not going to get points from Fabby I'm
not hitting you know how the Sharks
operate yeah I'll get points from you
yes and else sounds like well wait a
minute let me take that Target off my
back uh and uh
he would send a message
I'm not I'm not that easy Ray Robson
versus Fabi for just a moment when we
left it we left it in this position
again
um one of those positions where I like
uh the center and I was saying if black
ever gets in the simple C5 C takes D4
it's going to be four versus four one
versus one easy easy draw Ray Ray says
no no no no let me play this move D5
making it so that this Pawn remains on
the board now having said that well it
is a past bond that could remain on the
board I mean so it's unclear yes right
like you know it's still unclear they're
you know Fabi does have the open file
the open B file uh to work with it's not
just about structure and weaknesses in
this case the dynamic uh good piece
good piece and potentially very good
piece as well once you played Bishop of
six I started to calculate dtx6
intermediate move you take on day one I
take on December but anyway it was not
played Knights if I was on the board
well it's good I mean that you you just
immediately like sacrificing the pieces
give me someone's pieces to sacrifice
and I will do it still one of my
favorite quotes cracks me up every time
Michael Tall said that when he lost the
Soviet Championship all the Soviet
children were so happy because now they
could go back to learning how to defend
their pawns and pieces instead of
learning how to sacrifice them
they're very nice all right and we have
a guess back over to you Christian
we are here with Sam Savion team uh
result for you with the black pieces of
draw against Alex Slenderman take us
through the game uh well this is very
solid line in Catalan and he had an
interesting idea on Route 13 I believe
with A4
the idea is to play A5 and clamp down
the queen side
and kind of stops B6 in a way so I spent
some time here and I think I found a
very good way of playing against this
which is Rook FDA and now if he plays A5
I take on D4
uh Knight takes Z4 or maybe Netflix or C
takes yeah if she takes 95 I was
thinking
stop the action of the bishop he has to
go E4 he creates his own weaknesses
right should be okay it should be okay
and if he takes with the Knight Bishop
C6 oh very nice
yeah and now it takes takes taking
advantage of the fact that white cannot
take with the Knight because of the pin
they take a bishop E3 Rook AC and this
Pawn on A5 looks very nice but I'm
threatening Knight D5 I think I think
that's fine absolutely uh and he played
the move Knight to B5 first yes and were
you aware that you guys are following
this game between nihal and petrosia I
wasn't I mean he was yeah
and you play The Rook uh A6 Knight to D6
were you at all worried that maybe his
two Bishops if he takes only eight at
any point will be conclusive at all I
never allowed him to you don't but God I
just immediately took on D6 yes and the
point is if he takes Bishop D6 I have
Knight D5
attacking C2 which forces Bishop to xt5
and takes D6 and there's no more two
Bishops yeah and the other point is if
he picks with the Rook on D6 in the game
I have Knight D5
I think it's a very important move
because if C4 here instead of Bishop
yeah I was thinking either 93 or Knight
B6 I'm not sure which is better but
seems like Knight C3 Knight C3 might be
better I'm interesting when net C3 A5
does he take only two yeah it takes an
E2 cake Knight C3 Rook takes d8 Rook
takes d88 Knight C5
my lights are kind of awkward so
we should be a little worried at this
point but
I thought if it gets you have to
calculate and find a way to equalize
here some concrete way yeah yeah to to
make it but that's why I was also
considering that B6 after C4
18 C4
ah instead of 46. No rookie six is fine
and C4 yes C4 Knight B6
um
well Bishop takes C6
take note A5
cap takes takes
I thought there should be quite
equalizers it looks like there should
have a lot of pressure right
uh there has to be a way to simplify
that yeah
at some point one pawns are going to
despite one of the students that has
space for a fuse and then everything
Fizzles up absolutely and he played uh
five yeah e takes D5 initially it looks
like what has a small plus because of
this A5 but my pieces are on all an
ideal Square Rook seat which would be
596. it doesn't allow him to do anything
I just one quick question instead of F6
I go Bishop C4
uh what does it say 94 Knight C5 and he
said he wants to take on C5 and play
King E1
yes I was interested in this position
because I can play bring my king to C7
play B6 was he still within his
theoretical knowledge no no he wasn't he
was uh this was an idea where analyzing
after the game uh I'm guessing if I try
to bring my king he'll play H3 G4 and
he'll have counter play on the king side
two King seven maybe H3 yeah yeah
probably there's just it's just a drone
position drawn but still maybe white has
some right right slight chance so it's
better just to trade the knights off
yeah absolutely well Sam how would you
assess your first couple of games and
how do you feel personally about torment
and about your shape that you are in uh
well I know Alex is a very strong player
and with black unless you take real
risks in the opening it's not easy to
beat him so I decided to play solid line
and you know I'm happy with it
absolutely and how about your form in
this tournament how do you feel after
the first couple of rounds I'm feeling
pretty good I'm seeing a lot of tactics
and calculating well so that's good
great to see that we'll see you in the
next couple of rounds thank you well
done uh Sam and there we have our
results uh a single game only one only
one drop and uh everybody is still at
play I'm just looking at the game of
Hans uh Neiman and Jeffrey Sean as we
prepare for a break I like what Jeffrey
has done it's kind of counter-intuitive
it it certainly it feels like the Knight
on D6 you know is so powerful right it's
centralized in the middle of the board
but then after you see this move Bishop
A4 you kind of stop and say well exactly
what is the Knight doing on D6 is it
attacking a king on E8 no the king's not
on the attacking upon on B7 yes but even
if you win that pawn on B7 you know like
you know how how big is the Applause I
agree with you but like we know that
nights on six or third rank normally
feel really great yes but I mean the
only thing with the Knight is doing like
maybe preventing black from putting his
business on certain squares that's the
only thing I can can see here like C8
query like seven square is taken at the
moment are taken at the moment so right
I'm not uh I'm not doubling Brooks on
the Empire yes on the other hand I am
attacking the pawn on C2 and I still
remember a very nasty little idea that
uh Christian had shared this move Rook
F2 uh taking advantage of the fact that
we have a discover check if you take the
rook and you kind of castled into some
serious uh
um initiative threats that black can
create here with the bishop under on pre
the pawn on C2 also on pre finally I
just want to say that when I was playing
the French defense and I was always
seeking to trade my light squared Bishop
unless the light squared Bishop had a
fabulous fabulous role then I was like
hey look at my great light Square Vision
I suddenly my bad Bishop was my favorite
bishop and with that we're just going to
go to a commercial break anything from Q
Boutique
Boutique not anymore but we'll submit
soon all right with our viewers see you
on the other side of the bridge
[Music]
surprised
he intrigued be delighted the World
Chess Hall of Fame in St Louis is
nothing you'd expect and everything you
love three galleries highlight the
history culture and creativity behind
the game explore chess in ways you never
imagined it's a one-of-a-kind cultural
institution where rare artifacts and
world-class art play together the World
Chess Hall of Fame mind art experience
can you hear it it's the sound of Hope
and health
and strength it's the sound of
compassion of open doors where people
and machines are in tune and miracles
occur
it's the sound of personalized health
care and active communities
like life
and it's what you hear when you really
listen
foreign
[Music]
and health
and strength
it's the sound of compassion
of open doors
where people and machines are in tune
and miracles occur
[Music]
personalized Healthcare
[Music]
and active communities
it sounds like life and it's what you
hear when you really listen
listening to you caring for you we are
Ascension
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to round two we have now
results for men's section right for the
open section sorry and only one result
only Alex Linderman made a draw against
Sam Sabian and the rest of the games are
still on the way good for us very good
for us lots and lots to talk about well
let's open up our coverage of round two
the game between Lavon and Lanier
Dominguez these two heavyweights coming
in as favorites in this tournament in
fact I have Levon as my personal pick we
saw Yes saw this position after F5 as uh
this move definitely spices up the
position it's one of those Bishops
versus nice imbalance and it invites a
mistake Knight takes F5 would have been
a trap that
Lavon would have said for example after
H3 Queen G3 oops Rook takes F5 there
goes one
Queen H4 whoops there goes two and
finally of course Queen takes D4 winning
upon and there goes three now all those
cases you would lose a piece move your
queen back to H5 and it gets forked by
G4 wow so uh I know so uh uh Lanier
found himself having to play this
awkward move G6 takes F5 and now
suddenly after this move Bishop uh H6 we
can see even at the cost of having
opened up the g g file a bit against his
own King the pawn structure is what's
taking precedence as Lavon is looking to
take capture on F5 and then thanks to
the split pawns uh stand better we'll
keep an eye on that very very technical
uh game something I enjoy a lot but uh
maybe Christian you've got some tactics
that you want to share with us oh
there's so many tactics going on in
every single game right now but check
this one out Wesley versus Christopher
and I want to point to the fact that uh
in the final position right now Wesley
has only 13 minutes to go in Christopher
45 so this is a big differentiator in
the assessment of that one but let's
take a look at how we got there because
we were saying that Wesley's taking over
at this point not so easy after F3 he
did find the move Queen to H4 very very
good move critical move if you don't
find that move then you're just simply
lost yeah so what will happen if you
take only four just a minute if you take
a knight right yes yes yes this is a
very good question Anastasia this is the
point this is the key point because not
only that I'm threatening the pawn on G2
I'm also threatening to go F2 so for
example if you go Knight to G3 I can
take on G3 but I can also just simply go
F2 and at this point I think you're
pretty much forced to give up your queen
if you go uh in the corner with King to
H1 not only that I'm going to pick up
your Rook but I'm also picking up on G3
and you are pin you cannot recapture
you're gonna get checkmated it's not
feasible foreign
[Laughter]
that's the one all right
of course he did not play that he did
not take on e4 did not bite the bait
Rook to H6 H3 and this was the critical
moment actually what Wesley had to do
probably to preserve his Advantage was
to take on e4 take only four first give
up the pawn on H2 that's okay you can
take my opponent H2 you're not going to
Checkmate me you only have the queen and
the Rook but the Rook is not doing as
much King to F1 not only that but it's
very critical that we're preserving
these pawns facing each other this
bishop is not getting active anytime
soon you have to try to do that with
Bishop to d8 but now I have time to go
D5 and this bishop on e4 it creates a
shield for my king right so I'm going to
go D5 sure you probably will get to my
king and for example D5 Queen to H1 I'm
not going to go King to F2 and allow
Bishop to H4 that would be devastating
for my position but what I can do is
play for initiative and compensation
allow you to go upon ahead with a queen
takes G2 but after King to D3 or King to
D1 I like King to D3 just because it
looks uh nice it looks like I'm in the
middle of the board I might get
checkmated but I'm not because you don't
have a way to get to it Queen takes it
to King takes it too and now the
position seems to be better the Knight
on A6 is not playing sure you have a
couple of uh very powerful pawns on the
H and G files but look at my Bishops
right specifically look at this bishop
on e4 but also the bishop B2 I'm going
to go Rook to G1 and Target The Pawn on
G7 it's looking like white has more than
enough compensation if not from a
practical perspective close to winning I
really like this position for white he
did not go for it and by the way guys we
do have the first result in the ladies
section there is a drop between uh I do
believe that's Jennifer you versus tatev
abrahamian
okay that is a task versus yes
and what happened uh it it Wesley didn't
go for that he did not go for that he
actually played the move H3 and I'm
actually kind of curious only thought
for two minutes for this movie H3 still
okay he doesn't have that much so he
doesn't have a lot of time yes exactly
yeah he did not leave himself enough
time to calculate all of this uh
complications and assess them Knight to
G5 was played and check this out after
Queen to F2 Queen takes H3 was on the
board oh my God you could have played
this Christopher could have played this
take advantage of the fact take take on
F2 when you take on F2 back I have Rook
to H2 and the bishop on B2 is hanging
still the position doesn't finish here
by any means because despite the despite
of the fact that you are a couple of
Pawns up as black your pieces are still
a bit misplaced right okay Knight on A6
I can invade with the move Rook to E7
now I have a clear threat to take on A6
and take on C7 you have to be careful
still a lot of compensation for white if
you go Rook F7 I can just make a draw
Rook to E8 Rook to E7 and so on but this
is what we have right now he did not see
Queen takes H3
b598 A4 came on the board after Queen to
H5 when he was challenged with Queen to
F2 this is what we have right now once
again it feels like black has the easier
play right this bishop on B2 is not
really a threat how are you going to
open up the position I understand you're
pushing your pawns and pushing your
pawns but I do feel like I'm getting
closer and closer to your king at some
point Knight takes H3 is going to come
on the board you have to be very careful
also still Queen takes H3 is on tap as
well so
very dangerous position for Wesley with
the white pieces objectively the
computer is saying that
Wesley should probably have enough
compensation on the queen side if he's
fast if he times his expansion very
precisely and already he did not do that
A5 was the right move he played him of
King to G1
after Knight to D7 actually never mind
the pawn is on A4 Knight to D7 has not
arrived on the board yet by Christopher
you nevertheless 97 is kind of a natural
move I want to say I'm looking at the
time I see 13 minutes for uh for Wesley
39 minutes for Christopher you and I
start getting worried for Wesley a quick
question uh why did Wesley play the move
a3a4 not Rook E7 at once uh a Christian
A4 uh I am the last move yeah rookie
seven uh various H3
cannot invade so you have to do
something with your pawns clears on the
concepts by the way uh 1987 was not
played Bishop to d8 I have to say I'm
really impressed with how fast
Christopher is making his decisions
that's a very good sign for a young man
that wants to improve he's not doubting
his moves at all and it shows he's
putting a lot of pressure on Wesley
Seoul right now on the other hand there
was a couple of critical moments even in
the previous game that maybe she should
have spent a bit more time and find this
like really really important decision
it's a very important decision
is what you're referring to it's still
you know he is looking for some balance
it's always difficult to find this
balance always difficult to understand
which positions they actually have to
spend lots of time and which positions
they have to play really fast exactly
Michael Tall said you know you find a
good move stop think about it maybe
there's something better
but if you stop and think about them
there's nothing better and you regret
the time that you spend maybe the
movement this was not there and
sometimes it's just not easy to find
that right balance between good play and
fast play eight Lots uh three results
check the moradia body game guys Alshon
versus a Wonder
oh my goodness isn't that just it's a
resignation time prettiest pair of uh
passers that you're you're ever likely
to see those pawns on A6 and B5 and
these Rooks are completely huddled I
mean
black doesn't even have a move no he's
going to be
uh yeah
going to E4 maybe like what do you play
after Queen E4 Queen E4 eyeballing E8
it's funny that you looked at Queen E4
the first one I was thinking is like
let's cozy on up okay ocean is enjoying
himself look at that believe it or not I
was thinking about yes moving forward
because everything looks so beautiful
sadist just very nicely putting
everything on light squares uh sometimes
that's just an easy one as well looks
like a wonder is definitely losing this
one again let's just uh go around the
horn a little bit I want to stay in
touch with the Hans Neiman game between
Jeffrey and Hans okay funnily enough
after Bishop A4 we did see B3 we did see
Bishop uh yeah but we're just Jeffrey's
one move away from getting a very very
nice grip on the position but B4 still
feels like White's the one in charge
all of these strange pawns Bishop C4
that looks like a good move King h8
inviting Bishop takes because I'm pretty
sure Jeffrey is thinking that he'll move
his Bishop somewhere let's say G6
exactly and somewhere he's he's
eyeballing chance of rookie eight and
stuff like this feels like it's better
for white because of the structure but
um
probably closer closer to a draw darish
and Sam Shanklin that looks like it's
going to be a draw we have a guest in
studio over to you Christian thank you
Yasser uh we are with abrahamian Tate
first of all congratulations you started
off against the two top rated players in
the event Irina Crush atomski two draws
how would you assess your performance
um
I mean I'm happy with my results I had
two shaky games I mean my game today was
pretty uneventful but at some point I
just couldn't make any decisions and I
got really long time so I think let's
talk about it
I've had experience yesterday let's
discuss this game for a brief moment
okay tell me about the key moments
I mean I just I know
I was just so tired today on honestly I
just couldn't make moves but I mean
there's not much here
what did I play here I went P6 I mean
did you feel like she was putting any
pressure out of the opening
four when she took Bishop F6 I thought
it was pretty simple because now all of
a sudden all my moves now I have to
think about like C5 and then okay we go
for
did you discuss with her did she know
about this no let me try this okay I
didn't get a chance to talk to her after
but yeah sometimes she started thinking
and actually wondering what she's
thinking at that [ __ ] out of my Lego
Bishop page for it but she's gonna have
six and then should have gone F6 Knight
takes F6 yeah now all my pieces they go
I think
on their squares and then here we just
repeated it push 56. absolutely quite a
uh smooth let's say start the tournament
this is a very long tournament 13 Rounds
uh how did you strategize your
preparation coming into the event
um
did you do anything specific anything
special
um I have some like opening ideas
clearly I haven't played it yet but it's
a long tournament so I think important
segmentally to get ready for a long
tournament and I don't think it's very
important to press for a win every round
I mean at my point I might regret this
when I have too many draws but I think
at some point people will start to be a
lot of battles and um 13 Rounds people
will start getting tired something at
some point something will happen
absolutely guys enjoying the
conversation yes first of all I wanted
to say to touch that she's my pick and
you said that you were a little bit
tired but I hope that you will find the
energy and will like move forward first
of all and I felt your supporters thank
you thank you but really if you need any
support of it of course even extra
support so but I wanted to ask you about
the game yesterday that one at certain
point you got your chances
um it looked really like promising for
you the final position even like what
did you feel at this moment how did you
assess this position
yeah I mean that might be a decision I
regret because I had to make a concrete
decision to go for this Rook end game
and I couldn't calculate it out and I
talked about it after without 105 and
they both feel like of course like
you're the only one pressing you have to
force her find like critical decisions
even if you see it in your calculation
but like I calculated I couldn't find
anything concrete and then again I
started thinking too much and then I was
like okay like I don't wanna
spend too much time and then get into
some kind of weird Rook end game some
something that I made again regret so I
decided just to repeat
but what a nice sexual possibility then
that you had the chance to analyze it
with Fabi and Alejandro actually
[Laughter]
come on guys uh what did I do wrong are
they uh helping you are they training
you in this event at all or is just a
casual conversation we're just we're
just hanging out yeah
this is what happens when you're in St
Louis
some random Grand masses you just catch
them
okay thank you thank you and all the
best
and uh speaking of uh lady players I
just wanted to go to the game of Arena
uh crash and Sabina for just a moment
it's uh
two two Bishops versus two knights and
by the way just another result yes we
have a result Sam shankland made a draw
that was the four versus four Rook
ending and then I caught wind of it it
was three versus three looked like a
draw two Bishops versus two knights in
an open position normally uh the Bishops
absolutely absolutely dominate in this
case because of this weak Pawn on E3
maybe maybe Sabina has some small
compensation I just I love the two
Bishops in these types of positions but
then again uh do we have something very
concrete after Knight C5
um it's wreath hanging right yeah but I
I I was raised on these Classics you
know the double Bishop sacrifice I even
for God who dubbed
poker game yes she sacrificed I remember
those two Bishops uh G7 H7 exactly
exactly
but it doesn't work unfortunately it's
genius but it's not good uh Queen takes
E3 check and just before I give you mate
what you give me I guess and D1 oh well
I tried to try this yes
a heroic effort
um yeah uh okay so Queen E7 and Rook F4
is on the board we'll see how uh these
two uh play and finally before we go
over to the open I wanted to go to Alice
Lee because she's playing against bacon
there you you are Alice Lee oh Bishops
of opposite color sorry to say
this appears like it's heading towards a
repetition oh wait a minute oh it's not
a I was about to say I was thinking
maybe Rook C7 check Rook D7 something
like this might be a repetition but no
this is the this is the first time
and uh with the eight well okay
um open section what's going on
Christian well I mean I'm still looking
at this game between Wesley and
Christopher you and finally there's a
moment where Christopher could
potentially take over the initiative by
sacrificing a piece yes so he gave
Wesley so he gave him the option after
A4 Bishop to d8 we said that this is a
very good practical move setting up this
potential to go to H4 with the bishop
and attack the queen and the Rook on the
same diagonal so very uh intriguing
options for black queen to F7 King to F1
and check this out now it's maybe
finally time to sacrifice the night
night thanks H3 let's see take the bull
by the horns and try to put a lot of
pressure on your opponent with this
exchange how would you continue as white
it does feel especially with how much
time does Wesley have only 10 minutes at
this point on his clock and still nine
moves go so
if black decides to go Knight takes H3
and it's objectively good as well I
think Wesley might be in some sort of
danger for example if you go Queen to G2
now you are now we understand why this
queen first retreated to F7 to put the
rook in front and then go behind the
rook and now you have all these ideas of
Rook to H1 followed by Rook to H2 or
Bishop to H4 there is a lot of
checkmating threats coming in your
position if you go King to G1 Rook to G3
is coming that wins on the spot it's
looking good I have to say for
Christopher you for the young
Christopher you in this one if he
decides to go for that he did not he
played Knight to D7 but that's the
beauty about this position you have time
white doesn't actually have a lot of
things to do except to try to go A5 but
from a psychological point of view
you're getting massacred on the king
side you see that there are some
exchanges there are some Knight takes H3
sacrifices coming in the position and
what you're going to focus on this side
try to break try to get a break on the
queen side psychologically is not that
easy so what you're focused on as white
is defense defense defense here oh as I
was saying that yeah five he's looking
for his own counter chances there we go
we have a game guys and we might see at
some point a sacrifice coming from young
Christopher you maybe he's setting it up
with Knight to F6 Knight to H5 Knight to
G3 perhaps he will get a bit over
ambitious but let's wait and see how
this one is going to play out I have to
say Christopher you is playing a good
game of attacking chess well the move A5
to my eyes kind of throws Down The
Gauntlet because black uh party V6 is
coming yeah black is facing A6 when this
entire entire structure is simply under
too much pressure it's about to collapse
so
now or never normally when you're young
you're not attached to Pieces so much
you know you're ready to give them to
your opponents so I really hope that you
will sacrifice in this game something in
this game even though he has Restless in
front of him it's really difficult
come on first do it 15 years young wow
yes sir imagine yourself
I was trying to get from the expert to
the master class all right it's time to
take it failing I was failing guys
Christopher ready to play the comment
combination do it you can do it no no no
here I know
you like that hovering over the pieces
yesterday I hate to have a you're a big
fan yes I hate the hovering oh my God
yes imagine someone you already such a
fresh under such a pressure like Wesley
so he sees of course this opportunity
and your opponent is doing all these
moves I mean you are like completely
crazy
is he going to take it I think well does
he have a choice I don't think so A6 is
just resigns
right that is correct that is correct
Knight takes H3 come on
and the Time by the way we we talked
about maybe oh he seems to his hand is
going towards d8 or D7 I don't know
Wesley is there maybe Knight D7 is his
intention no
97 to H5 to G3 that's too slow I agree
that that's what I thought he's going
for but A6 is coming and it's so
powerful
yeah now you have to take on age this
moment of hesitation is really crazy
it's like how much time does Christopher
have I know that Wesley's shorts
yes okay no of course you have to yeah
great and I held my breath for so
well too much Rook takes H3 now you want
to of course get on your sneakers and
run to the king E1 to D2 but King E1 is
walking into this massive Bishop H4 so
that was why we went Queen G2 to get out
of the way but Queen H5 threatening the
pawn on F3 threatening uh help me out
here because I I missed him I'm missing
a move but the other guest in studio as
well we're going to let West is so think
about this one he only has 10 minutes
but we do have Darius verch with us in
the studio Darius a difficult encounter
with a very well prepared Sam Shanklin
he surprised you with this uh Broomfield
now he didn't surprise me with the group
he does surprise me I actually was
expecting it I mean some place many
openings of course his trustable courses
on semislava are like really famous I
was looking outside other openings but
yeah gloomfield was one of his main
openings and I was expecting I wasn't
really expecting it so uh yeah I had
this line Bishop C4 prepared and
actually and I thought
um all right it's interesting try for
sure
um
and uh yeah this E6 line that some
played uh yeah it's uh by surprise no I
was not surprised actually uh
I guess I can say it uh I analyzed it
very deeply for my upcoming Festival
course oh so all right for white so uh
yeah here is one of the lines that I
analyzed pretty deeply and actually I
had a game like this already two weeks
ago which is probably not published or
like it's maybe hard to find but I had a
game against the attacker actually I
played tournament Poland two weeks ago
the rapid tournament in Poland and uh
yeah this was uh this is what yazak
played against me and I managed to win
this game so it was exactly up to move
like
uh 14. so yeah Bishop B3 and now yeah so
basically yazak played against me in
this position Bishop B5 which is a big
mistake uh because right now Rook takes
d8 Rook takes d8 94 and uh the problem
is that right now let's say we should
goes to A6 or something and I can play
with F4 which is a very important detail
because there is no Knight G4 and
usually this person you want to play
Knight G4 but in this case you can do
this because there is Knight X E6 very
nice so so this is one of the main ideas
uh and after a four wide General
speaking better of course the game goes
on but what is better but some played
Bishop C6 pretty quickly and I could not
recall what is like my exact analysis
there I just could not recall at all and
I believe that some worked out to a draw
or something but still I thought that
this is uh I mean I'm sure I had it in
my analysis for trustable course but I
just could not really recall this again
like some like 2021 Bishop g47 I hit him
play E6 so really it was difficult for
me to you know anticipate everything and
I just did not remember this particular
position with 56 so I played a three
which I thought which felt right look at
this year is probably correct and he
played it quickly he played also very
quickly yes and here I had made really a
lot of a lot of options I've had 94
interesting and I have four interesting
I have Rook a B1 uh I mean I just I mean
really really vast choice but I just
uh I mean I didn't remember I had
analyzed for sure I just didn't remember
and uh yeah I decided to play it on the
four and I think it was a decent try a
504 is usually good for black to include
these moves uh Bishop E8 yeah and this
was the first move that Sam actually
thought about yeah yeah so I thought it
was good news that he finally thinking
yeah of the book uh yeah King F1 never
never crossed my mind of course uh King
F1 yeah I don't know how great it is but
but uh yeah Samsung told them after
games but each thing is just equalizing
immediately which
probably this but I my suspicion is
still there is some game I guess I don't
know
um I don't know I'm just not sure after
King to F1 actually the best movie is
Bishop page six anyway so he does seem
like he knew about this he knew any
ideas I was I wasn't familiar here
already so anyway I played this visual
D4 which felt pretty natural and here
and I think it was very strong move and
yeah here I spent lots of time
calculating at 86 and I was really
tempted to do this and but my the reason
why I didn't do this is King f8 the
takes takes takes on G7 probably and not
the the thing that you have to look ab1
if some place Rook C7 or something I
play Ruby five and I'm winning or
something exactly he's winning yeah I
thought I have very good chances here to
be one there's no way basically he
cannot regroup but the point is that he
has Knight d8 instead of an idea and
he's managing to establish beautiful C6
night Bishop Knight comes to E6 and all
my weaknesses are just collapsing
absolutely so uh okay engine give zero
zero but I thought if anyone's taking
any risk here is zero zero after rotates
d8 which is not yeah actually I was
thinking about it I was as fast as like
this could be a draw but uh again it's
not something want to play right so
that's for this reason I decided not to
do this and
yeah actually it's very one more
important detail here after Knight takes
E6 because it may be tempting to play
build after Bishop B6 Bishop F7 but
visual 7 is a big mistake because uh in
the same position I play in the end Rook
D7
this is a very important detail exactly
uh I saw that during the game and as far
as where I'm winning but I realized
Bishop is not someone wants to keep the
Bishops to these six and it's I'm not
playing this for a win for sure yeah so
uh this is what I was thinking so I said
in the end decided to keep it simple
deck on G7 play 93 because I wasn't sure
how he's gonna establish I mean like how
he's going to capture my opponent on C5
of course 96 or 9b97 but I thought that
Bishop C4
97 should be five and I fought here like
in the end of this car like exchanges
and so on I have room D7 and he still
needs to be a bit careful which probably
is true he plays and say on like Rook
ACA let's say probably I don't know
exactly I was thinking B1 or something I
can play and he is in some trouble uh
but very precise Rook ed8 is just pretty
much liquid into a draw right away yeah
and the rest of the game I mean it was
we played a couple of more moves but
yeah uh it's just the drawer so Doris
how would you assess your form up to
this point and based on the first couple
of games yeah I feel pretty good I feel
pretty good yeah yesterday I had a very
interesting game against Jeffrey and I
was I mixed up my opening but uh I mean
yeah I was in big trouble actually
strategically but in the uh critical
moment I've decided to play this movie
E5 which actually as I checked later was
a good try and I'm surprised to see that
I mean I
I'm surprised to see there's no losing
sort of because I just found my I felt
really shaky at this moment like one
person was very shaky but uh after
Jeffrey didn't take this Pawn or I
played E4 actually engine is giving the
black is better and I had no I couldn't
I didn't realize that sort of that's why
I played kind of a couple of passive not
really possible I stay in place trying
to get them 40 and uh in this basically
just end up uh with let's say a bit
worse than game but definitely holdable
because just such a block item B5 must
give me drawing choices but again if I
if I realize I'm better I would
definitely come up with I mean I saw of
course the idea of 96 95.93 and I wanted
to do that but the question is if I'm in
time because capturing my pollen A4 so
it was not obvious to me at the at the
board I said play something safer as
well give me the drop but overall I am I
feel good I feel really good so I'm
looking forward to more games still the
start of the tournament a very long
tournament ahead of yourself good luck
in the possible games thank you and good
luck indeed I just want to turn our
attention to the game of Naji and Megan
Lee Megan made a sham sham sacrifice the
idea of Hashem sacrifices though she
sacrificed a piece she understood that
she was winning it back right away after
Knight takes E5 Bishop takes E5 Bishop
F6 F4 D6 and thanks to the fact that
oops
the king is still in the center of the
board the bishop on E5 couldn't move and
in this position
uh Megan is just doing great she's a
pawn up and uh well everything is going
uh fantastically for her with a very
obvious E5 E4 I would assess the
position is winning for black thanks to
the fact that this bishop is now shut in
this bishop is a monster this Knight on
D2 is Tethered to this Pawn on C4
everything has gone perfectly for Megan
Lee so just uh
out of the alert if you will I wanted to
also go back of course to our game
between Christopher and
um Wesley because it was actually funny
uh I was I just certainly didn't see the
move I talk about blindness but I was
wondering what on Earth Wesley was going
to do here because he's facing this
horrifying threat of Rook H1 check
followed by Bishop H4 you can resign
once that arrives uh move rockef 2 just
wasn't there yeah I just didn't see it
and then suddenly okay now I understand
what Wesley is saying if you play Bishop
H4 well I'm ready to take a rook if you
play Rook to G3 well I'm ready to allow
for Pat yeah and I would be very happy
to get out of this situation yeah yeah
it would be very happy to get out of
this game alive with a draw and finally
if you play rookie eight I think
Wesley's just in time to bring his
Knight G1 Square to block this fateful
Rook H1 mating idea so very nice defense
I didn't say rookie back over to you oh
no yeah back over to you Christian uh
what do you think about Wesley's defense
well it's definitely a good defense
nevertheless black has two very pleasing
options right now as you guys were
mentioning Rook to G3 and just make a
rook G3 Queen H2 to H3 if you want that
but Rook to E8 is indeed very powerful
and how do you defend
um to keep you away from the E2 square
root to H1 is a big threat right yeah
you have to address that somehow so he
does feel like Knight to E2 might be the
way to do so right the problem is you
still have some weaknesses who's first
who's first am I going to be the first
one to Checkmate your king or are you
going to be able to find a way to
destabilize my position on the queen
side and uh promote one of your pawns
well let's take a look if you go away
six right I'm going to take on F3 F3 yes
if you take on B7
Rook takes F2 or Rook to H1 both of them
seem to be decisive because after you go
Knight to G1 I can just simply pick up
your Bishop that's fine you're getting
close but you're also getting checkmated
unfortunately
that's nice that's a Checkmate you got
close
really really close to to getting a
queen on the queen side
though you're not there yet so right now
what Christopher has to do he has to
stop and start calculating put more
pressure on your opponent this is move
35 still five moves to go for Wesley
and he did not play rookie eight he
repeated once ah he repeated the
position no wait what did he do nothing
he's thinking I think he's just thinking
so Wesley but Wesley just scribbled
something on his scoresheet so I assume
that he made a move okay maybe he was
hovering and Wesley was getting ready to
write something on the uh often times in
those moments I I've also used those
moments to check the clock and I'd
sometimes write how much time uh so but
it's forbidden now you know what to
write you write the clock time yeah you
cannot you cannot write anything on your
score sheet not even the time no but you
remember what happened with Western I
think of course I remember that he was
around Tony Rich uh throws the world
champion and forfeits of mine the
competition I said what are you doing
Tony you got your Arbiters title now
suddenly you want to exercise your fruit
your your your your powerful privileges
yes I think version can tell us more but
he is no yeah well there's a score sheet
yeah he's just ready to go but uh does
that look like sometimes yes maybe
you're right so there are definitely
some scribbles
no I think he's putting the the clock
times and you're telling me that's
illegal no I know that normally you
cannot do it you're gonna try dancing
except the moves so writing something
yes you see these little circles yes I
see where that that that's for the time
that's for the time yes oh I I don't
want to go for this but
okay boy hold on
the things are made I mean Zero
Tolerance I I always like writing down
the moves because I would reflect later
and say well it took me 20 minutes to
make that decision why did it take me 20
minutes nowadays you go to chest and
foreign
because I think this is why he lost the
game he was writing some motivational
quotes right on his scoresheet right
yeah like and he lost that game right
but this is I thought
the clock is a part of the game it's the
equipment
maybe something else you've been using
those two did Christopher play rookie no
no he's still thinking he's still
thinking what else he can play Wesley's
still right
he's throwing me off man Wesley is
anxious uh hoping the young man will not
find the move rookie eight but we're
rather uh go for the repetition with
Rook G3 and Rook H3 yes let's not forget
he please let me one of the best players
player in the world Wesley so I mean
from psychological point of view we can
still let me mention this that it's like
intimidating a great result to make a
draw with the player of this caliber
right absolutely and they're also
missing one very important tool at this
point in any open tournament Wesley
would probably be like hey Christopher
do you want to make a draw right they
can't make a draw first no no you cannot
do that in this tournament so you cannot
offer your opponent dry you cannot give
your opponent that chance
wow I mean it's interesting I mean what
kind of decision I'm sure he feels that
this attack is pretty strong and he has
Reds but at the same time you have
rookie 8 has to be considered though yes
because it's a checkmating threat but
you should find this movie
because after 92 91 I mean white brings
one more piece for defense for the
defense so you should see the rookie
three very good move which you mentioned
uh threatening Bishop on D3 born on F3
so it's but it is a forced move yeah I
agree so you have to calculate force
moves always is it to comment but very
hard to play when you under such a
pressure absolutely absolutely yeah so
and although we didn't we were looking
at A6 and other ideas uh if we have
simply moved the bishop and allowed Rook
takes H3 Rook takes F3 is this so bad
it's so bad thank you I'm not sure is it
so bad or not yes right I mean okay uh
deep breath and let's see if we can run
for the Hills right yeah
uh but oh rookie three F3
I'm not running very far am I uh Nike I
think that F3 is coming as well yeah
yeah Knight G1 maybe 91
well maybe I can even take on H2 wait
wait wait go sorry you don't have to and
then go Rook H2
[Laughter]
that's a refreshing
and by the way breaking news and the
game between our birthday boy yes
we got no presents no presence sometimes
it's a prison it could be a draw with
Lanier yeah so draw was your friend now
you can go and share a cake that was not
a friendly draw I was not a friend no no
it was definitely on the back foot in
that one exactly exactly
actively losing at one point but he was
objectively winning in his game against
Fabiano in the first round so maybe
there's a balance there I always uh like
like this one story I I it's very rare
for me to actually play an opponent on
their birthday I just don't remember
having done that except in the world
team uh competition in China it was a
pairings US versus Hungary and I was
playing Judith Polgar you know the
opening before the game began the the
Arbiters a few kind words about what
we're going to do and by the way
congratulations to miss Judith Polgar on
her birthday I was like Judy I didn't
the birthday and she's asked her you can
give me a present please take anything
you want off the board remembering that
Bobby Fischer famously challenged women
said I can give a night to any woman in
the Soviets said okay
we'll accept obviously maybe not so fast
oh my God I wanted to show my respect to
Judith and to show that and to Bobby and
to show how much progress women's chess
had made I reached across the board and
I took away her night so that she could
give me the odds of a night she said
give me back my knife
and I held it till the gone
very reluctantly and her first move was
night on F6 toga did G8 to F6 yes it was
very funny it's a really funny story
yeah but I respect uh did we see rookie
eight we haven't yet but I have a
question before we go to that one before
we go back to that what's happening in
this game is white still that winning
the game between more and I wonder
because
what happened if you go H7 I'll take it
take that and I will say thank you very
much I can take my phone on D6 no
problem but I'm pretty sure this is the
trouble yes after G5 you can even take
and then route to G6 I'm pretty sure
even this is a draw yes I agree so you
have to be very careful with all a and
it actually is a drop because we have
table base
he played Queen C6 you don't
but it's not that easy anymore right no
absolutely not I thought he should have
taken the bishop with his Knight the
Knight was on D7 yes and I really
thought it was the bishop
that oh yes Knight to D7 Knight to D7
was much better than Knight takes E8 yes
absolutely you take this one and then
you go right and so on because uh yeah
uh the the Rooks are very ineffective
the bishop is actually now this is not
that easy anymore yes okay I'm pretty
sure it's still winning you have to find
a way to include your king into the
attack destabilize The Rook from the B
file and maybe go maybe six if you can
get B6 and preserve one of your pawns
then you're going to be winning not as
easy as it sounds anymore though no I'm
a little bit worried for airshot but
still but maybe my eyes this is the big
one this is the big one between
um excuse me Wesley and Christopher will
he find Rook to E8 or will he not
um yeah and I'm also looking at the game
between Hans Neiman and Jeffrey Zhang
interesting after uh Bishop takes E6
Jeffrey went for Bishop to A4 and after
castles long we were really we were all
just kind of expecting that Jeffrey
might be trying to push this bishop away
and capture the pawn he went E3 and he
said just a second I've got ideas of
Rook F2 and attacking the pawns on G2
and C2 Rook F1 and I think we've caught
up
not quite up to date with the players
look F1 G6
well wait a minute uh
kind of getting nervous here for Jeffrey
because first of all that Bishop on G4
defends E2 yes but it also stops The
Rook from ever landing on C8 and that
bought on the east side what do you mean
nervous for Jeffrey yeah Sir Jeffrey
might be losing atmosphere yes that's
what I'm thinking that he's that he
slipped up with these last uh a couple
of moves here I think he slipped up long
time ago even Hansa has been playing a
very very good game okay since the
opening since he found that move Bishop
to Eaton did not allow that Rook to F2
you guys remember yes
he did not fall for that yes yes he
positioned into this end game in which
he's just much better right yeah because
of all these double pawns great
structure right
castle at the right moment
no it's it's not necessary that he
didn't fall for this idea maybe he just
developed the piece and that it helped
didn't happen now uh how bad is it in
terms of evaluation when in fact Bishop
to G4 was uh not the most precise and
right now he's only 0.9 maybe he's
falling a little bit nevertheless
there's still a lot of pressure on
Jeffrey Jeffrey with only four minutes
and 30 seconds right now and Counting so
he has to make some really good moves
Rook fe8 is the best move in the
position will he find it Rook Cafe is
suggestive because after E6 I do have H5
and it's what we call an overloaded
Bishop has to cover E2 by the way
breaking news make them did make them
they did defeat a former a U.S Champion
today with the black pieces yes and it
has two out of two right I think so yes
yes two attitude it was washingtonians
are tough you know
maybe yes yes
one step forward
price okay so Rook fe8 uh is actually uh
Jeffrey's best bet and maybe he's in the
game came back to Christopher you can
our 15 year old upset the reigning U.S
champion
and that move rookie eight rookie three
sure is suggestive though because
whenever you're on the attack you're
always asking yourself
are my pieces playing an active role
obviously the Knight on D7 nothing to
say about that the bishop yeah you would
like that Bishop to be on G3 but it's
not going to get there
the only other piece The Rook on f8 that
The Rook on The Rook because it's so
mobile uh so
um you can so easily plant itself into
an attack you start to think
I should be able to play Rook F6 or Rook
G6 nope yes the bishop on D3 I should be
able to play rookie eight and rookie
three oh I like it so that move uh the
geometry draws your eye of course you're
panicking that A6 and you're collapsing
and so you've got to deliver mate you've
got to play rookie eight yeah I mean you
can start to see some ghosts definitely
and these positions with this A6 and you
may might think that maybe those phones
will be promoted just sooner later but
yeah I mean that's a good attitude that
if you are attacking someone you should
try to find a way to bring all your
pieces to into the into the game
absolutely and make sure everybody gets
an invite
not always but sometimes uh
well the other thing is if you don't
play rookie eight the only other move
that makes any sense is A6 but that's
just too slow I mean you're just you're
inviting I don't know takes takes and
once the night somehow lands on G1
the white king starts feeling a lot
safer so
you gotta hit right now what is the
times again 11 minutes
for a young Chris for you versus six
minutes and 45 seconds so he's
definitely catching up on time so the
tension
and Wesley
no it's very funny game like he tries to
make a move he's still ready to write
something down he's got the brackets
oh my goodness okay I'm getting ready to
write the move of his opponent but he
doesn't make it Jeffrey did play Rook on
f8 today yeah by the way and he's hoping
to Snapple that pawn on E5 and actually
Hans is now down to his last three
minutes and 50 seconds if I'm reading
that correctly so I think the the
tension across the board by the way
we're seeing a and I wonder what's the
clock in those two 27 minutes to oh but
they've made they made the time okay so
it's really Wesley they're Way Beyond
Time control at this point Ray Robson
and
um Bobby oh Fabi is definitely pushing
obviously pushing for an advantage to 39
seconds
what what come on it's it's Ray Robson
39 seconds is infinity for Ray Ross yes
yes
he's been there countless of times right
but this is our active yes when this
bishop on F6 I like this bishop very
much yes
and also like Knight C3 ideas with like
Rook D1 sometimes maybe if they look
absolutely oops Checkmate is Checkmate
yes uh from on White's side of the board
though he's sitting there just patting
himself on the back this Knight on C4
looks really good I but this Rook on B1
is not
is not great I'm thinking maybe 92.
somehow I need to
I need to activate my rook and get the
Rook into the game as we see Fabi
thinking in this moment what can he do
does he have some trickies
I can't believe he's thinking about King
D5 or
those kinds of things okay back to the
Wesley so game because we're just having
to see if Christopher will or will not
we just saw Rook D5 will Christopher
find the
um okay important blow Rook E8 I believe
we have a special guest in studio over
to you Christian we do have an early
leader in the ladies section Megan Lee
with two incredible victories this one
with the black pieces against a former
Champion tell us about that how do you
feel right now uh it's pretty exciting
um I'm just taking one game at a time
and this one was not an easy one because
she was putting a lot of pressure from
the beginning she surprised you in the
opening with this aggressive Scotch tell
us a bit about that yeah I wasn't
expecting her to play the scotch um
I think it's a little hard when you're
unfamiliar with like the setups to
figure out like a plan to do for both
white and black so since she hasn't
played it a lot I think she struggled a
little bit with coming up with a plan
for what to do and when did you feel
like her preparation finished
uh the rage for it felt like she still
knows exactly I think after she played
like Knight F3 she took like 20 minutes
or so so this was the big moment yeah
I do have three and you played Bishop A6
C4 C5
Knight to C6 Bishop to D2
and this was the critical moment after
D3 Knight to D2 it felt like she's
backing down a little bit did you feel
the same way uh yeah I think she spent a
lot of tempo moving her Knight around
while I was able to finish my
development so
um I think she has to play really
precisely otherwise it's a bit hard how
did you assess this position and how did
you come up with your plan for the next
few moves I was thinking after I played
H6 that I could try a break with G5 or
maybe play G4 so I think she was worried
about that um
but she played some moves to prevent it
so I came up with this other plan and I
think she missed Knight takes E5 here oh
Knight dc5 yeah this was the big one and
if she takes back you just go Bishop F6
open up set up this pin on the e-file
and then follow it up with this pick up
the bishop for free very nice very nice
maneuver found by you and nice tactics
E4 to B1 did you feel like you have full
control of the position at this point
yeah I think my pieces are pretty active
and I was I think I was able to maintain
the initiative here exchange the Queens
if possible and just take advantage of
your extra material very nice victory
for you Megan what are your Ambitions
coming into this event are you thinking
about that title at all no I'm not
thinking about it I think I'm just
trying to play my best chess I spend a
lot of time working at my job where it's
hard to find time to play chess so I'm
glad I was able to make time this time
how do you combine the two training for
such a big daughter on the weekends yeah
works pretty tiring
excellent guys join the conversation
just our congratulations indeed to you
Megan and keep up the good work go
Huskies
congratulations congratulations very
good and uh turning to the game of Hans
Neiman if it really feels like Jeffrey's
fully back in the game now I mean first
of all uh he's no longer a pawn down
very important uh secondly he's the one
with the big Paris pawn on E3 uh from
hanza's point of view Hans has control
of the open files the f file and ND file
which is compensation for this passer
but it's clear that uh Jeffrey the worst
is behind him I want to say it like that
I think at three result a game as as
possible a draw still the most likely
result and did we see him move from
Christopher we did see a move yes we did
we did see one repetition our repetition
oh one one repetition and right now
still thinking about no it's he will
repeat now I don't know he's down to his
last six minutes
you know I mean when you spend so much
time and precisely yes I don't think you
will go
result in the Ladies as uh oh he's going
for it guys he's going for it
Cervantes he's going for it he's going
to play rookie eight yes sir oh my God
really difficult
[Music]
imagine you have already
so he sees that he's got the draw in the
pocket he also he's thinking okay rookie
8 92 rookie three Knight G1 Rook takes
D3 A6 I could lose but it's tempting you
can also win against Wesley so with the
black pieces exactly there's precedent
Wesley so did lose in the American Cup
against Sam Seville with the white
pieces you can lose
so Christopher is definitely feeling
confident of course this is a big moment
right now for this young man
I mean it's really psychologically
difficult I know yes and not easy no no
for both of them I mean for Wesley also
to see he already of course calculated
I'm sure the book he ate and but he's
expecting it but at the same time to see
his opponent yeah
I remember I I was playing in this GMA
tournament in Barcelona and it was Gary
Kasparov yes the Gary Kasparov against
Raphael valganyan Gary was white and uh
Gary was in time trouble and I was
standing next to Jonathan Spielman as a
spectator and Gary made a move and
offered to draw and instantly yes
without any consideration vaganyan
continued the game wow and Jonathan look
turned at me and said nice
no intimidation at all you're the world
champion come on let's go
okay it was the draw but Gary had to
earn it I remember yeah you're 15 years
of age you have one of the best chess
players on the planet on the back foot
no but you have to continue the game you
see rookie eight you know that there's a
lot of threats and ideas in the position
the position is still rich but this is
how you do it just go for it yes you
take some chances nobody said it's going
to be easy right right so you have to be
brave he's only 15 years he has to be
brave in order to be this this
incredible players oh yeah I don't know
if what I would do playing with Wesley
clock is ticking your clock is ticking
now you're underneath yes on time before
you were enjoying a very nice luxury of
15-20 minutes that you're burning and
you've already made one repetition and
then you start thinking that Wesley is
one of the best players in the village I
think the moment you get to two minutes
it becomes a draw yes I don't think you
you go all the way down to 30 seconds
and say okay now I'm ready to play for
the win well he has two minutes and 50
seconds right now okay actually then you
say to your trainer that okay
he's going for it
I'm really happy that he made it yes I I
thought that he will just make go for a
draw exactly
and see what Wesley does now right this
is a big moment for Wesley as well
because the defense is not easy at all
is it any well King G1 might be asking
the right questions gy why not Defender
and then what about well with the ideas
we're going to play Asics and break
through over there we're losing a piece
but we don't want I guess to be under
the duress of Rook H1
and it's such a difficult position
defending the bishop well also very
sensible that is losing on the spot
after Bishop takes A5 that is the key
come on in your position Bishop takes
Asia they say five is crucial and
winning right now what is he even
looking at that side of the board first
of all if you take one of three which is
very tempting right there is this bishop
H7 at the end probably right at the end
of operation let's check the obvious
moves first and then come back oh if you
take on F3 you're actually just like
this yes
Discovery there's so many things that
you need to consider the idea of you
should buy five actually again
deflection like take the bishop and
again probably rookie or what it's a
crazy move yes not only that but it also
defends against Knight G1 because you
have rookie one Checkmate in one move
Bishop takes A5 Knight G1
in fact that's a threat after a [ __ ]
pay five not only that I'm picking up a
pawn I'm actually activating my bishop
and creating the threat of Rook H1 right
Knight G1 is no longer possible because
of rookie one that's it wow this is a
big moment for this young man's career
guys well Rook A3 first of all really
does ask the question what are you going
to do as you were saying Anastasia if
the threat was to play Rook takes F3 you
no longer have that yes but if you you
know objectively look at the position
and come up with a move Bishop A5 it's
not only hats off but he's not looking I
think he doesn't even look at this
direction the hand is not going to the a
pawn that's for sure what could where is
the hand going actually somewhere there
maybe Rock H1 yes Rook H that's a
tempting move as well and then Bishop
takes A5 that's an option you can do
that if you want
is the wrong sequence of moves because
now when you take on A5 I simply done
the wrong move
okay he's done it in the wrong sequence
it's still it's still good it's what
it's still good it's not that good but
he has to take on A5
I was thinking maybe he's a [ __ ] what
will happen if Bishop H4 Rook H1 check
King I yes you take the Rook what this
is the last move guys from time control
40th move besides Bishop A5 what else
while he's hovering over the bishop I
think he's gonna play Bishop H4 no but
that's not good now Queen H1 is coming
no hello Bishop F6 negative six no we've
said that this was too slow that the
Knight is never getting into the attack
and that the pawn can go to A6
uh and break up oh no I think he's a lot
I think he's gone he's lost his
Advantage guys totally
it's now equal
[Music]
beside the move Knight F6 what should he
have played uh five still Yes Bishop
taxi in fact Knight F6 is the second
best move in the position but that's the
problem he wasn't even looking that
direction yes Bishop takes A5 Bishop E2
now just take on A3 and play that
position and you have a peace yes Europe
is down but I have a lot of I have three
pawns after all and just Knight F6
you don't have any counter play anymore
yes you're still under an attack paint
wow uh dramatic moments here in round
two and you know what the problem is 15
year old nearly missed a win yes because
if you go Bishop D3
yeah keep going keep going no oh sorry
keep going in that way yes okay you
don't have a good way to uh reassess the
position and reshuffle your pieces
Bishop D3 is met with Knight E4
and if you take with the F Pawn there's
a Checkmate in the position
obvious
that is pretty embarrassing isn't it
it's I bet it's beautiful like you can
easily miss this Knight E4 easily if you
think was the bishop then Pawn takes yes
and it's three probably I don't know so
so the pawn is on A5 the Knight went to
F6 and why isn't like a I mean if if
this had been a Blitz game or yes you'll
play a six you would just have played A6
right away because yes since we made the
time control I think we have to go to
the Neiman game okay let's do it because
they're down to their last minute
fantastic but I think they've reached
time no six still six moves to go six
moves to those whoa whoa whoa and it
does feel like Jeffrey is back in the
game right
maybe even better in the position
as Hans just kind of let his Advantage
slip and well H5 is a kind of indication
that hey I'm the one playing exactly
exactly Rook C8 Rook E8 C8 that move
isn't obvious to me why did he make that
move Christian I think he's just trying
to go uh Bishop to E4 potentially
the thing is there's not a clear way to
break through and there's not a clear
way to make progress you just need to
pass the moment and make the time
control
but this is the key right now ask some
questions along the way that's why you
see all this shuffling of The Rook on
the eighth Rank and after that I'm ready
to go H5 then maybe I will go King H6
next move I have to be careful though
because Rook F7 is coming as well so
it's very difficult to make any progress
with either color right yes
it's not moving anymore well but just a
second one once again a little devil's
advocate for yours truly I love the move
H5 I really do I mean on a good day I
want to play H4 create a weakness and
then Target that weakness so I see the
move H5 and I don't understand the move
Rook C8
check that out Rook h8 then and he says
that the Rook on D3 is better placed
than the Rook on C3 so we play Rook C8
Rook C3 and now rookie okay yes finally
okay this one I get this one I
understand so I I mean if I'm in
um
um Jeffrey's shoes I'm thinking I want
to take I want to take and I want to uh
invade Rook H2 and let's go I mean after
all this Pawn on E3 is a is on your
doorstep I mean it's ready for a
coronation like me here and surprisingly
difficult to get rid of that Bishop on
C6 and the pawn on B5 right it looks
like the structure is bad but it's
actually holding off to your queen side
quite nicely your majority on the queen
side is obsolete right now
yes why and we do have a move actually
before he played yes I mean really okay
chain H4 H4 yes
that happens on the question three now
is a weakness yes but maybe how to
attack it you're right yes like maybe
so weak yes you call it weakness only if
you find the way how to take it
you tell me a weakness if you can is it
and The Rook after provoking H4 The Rook
came back to C8
that's intriguing whoa I
okay that's what do you think about age
four yes it does it feel wrong
from White point of view no I think I
think Hans made the right decision there
not to allow Jeffrey the opportunity
himself which always kind of begs the
question what if I played H4 I guess he
would take it Rook H4 and simply defend
yes something like this and simply
defend the pawn and it's well
I don't know I mean G5 H2 I started
thinking about these things before maybe
after G5 it takes H4
okay exchange but this is
it feels like this one's heading to a
draw guys they're just moving back and
forth at least
well both players for the moment
and uh Han says no no no no wait a
minute let's let's keep going the game
let's keep the game going let's keep it
alive at the end of the day it's nice
game to play right so it's just freaky
Play
broke down
who's pressing who yes okay F6 Bishop to
three so let's go rookie six challenge
that Rook on D6 right yeah I don't like
that one uh sitting there and again
because of Bishop D3 by the way all
right well let's uh let's leave the open
uh players alone a little bit and catch
up with them they should make the time
control on this one oh sorry because I
think we have only a couple of moves
left and still both uh down to their
left stream a couple of seconds Rook E7
the funny part about that move is that
it does prepare to meet the move Rook F6
with Bishop E8 and then maybe the
question is are the Rooks so great yes
here doubled on the sixth rank no then
you go on yes
we're about to play the bishop D3 and
allow E2 yeah but they too looks really
disappointed yes
yes no no no we don't allow such moves
though okay we go back we go back
correct for D4 which move number is that
39. I think they will make it I mean the
position is not so difficult let's say
compared to Wesley no no guys can I go
Bishop E4 now can I start looking at
your C2 Pawn now that your Rook is no
longer possible to get back on the C5
you don't have Rook C3 anymore yes I
think you tricked him he tricked him
yeah I I like it a lot actually Bishop
E4 and you start eyeballing that C2 Pawn
this is a big moment guys he could be
taking over the initiative if he finds
Bishop E4
is once you see the construction of the
Pawn on B7 the pawn on B5 once you see
this construction and how how it's so
good at keeping the three pawns the
majority under control you're kind of a
little reluctant to play Bishop before
he's on the board did he found it
so what you need to push C3 or whatnot
this is the last move
[Music]
somehow you're kind of opening I agree
with you but I'm trying to understand
what what to do oh yes oh there is a
detail
issue so yeah there are issues yeah you
cannot do it it doesn't look like the
type of position where white should be
worse right right no material is so
limited you have this ugly double pawns
on the beach but that E3 Pawn is so
strong it truly is
let's see what he goes for Rook C1 feels
like a natural move
D1
uh
Bishop C6
oh that was just a tease by Jeffrey
oh yes because
p7 check okay and Jeffrey said okay
let's make time control let me reset my
uh thinking and uh I'll uh I'll uh I'll
see if I have something uh later well
the time it's all made guys by the way
this last move Bishop C6 just does
suggest hey wait a minute don't leave
the f file in
too long I would like to take control of
the file let's just turn to the ladies
before we get ready for a break this is
the end of the game that Megan has won
uh let's jump to Alice Lee whoa who is
dominating right now what whoa It's The
Next Step piece that's that's it that's
the only thing which I can calculate in
this position
that's what I I usually count pawns you
started with phones right I started this
pieces it held yeah well in this case uh
you did really good uh I don't know
exactly how she lost her Bishop it was
Bishops of opposite colors I thought yes
yeah there was this uh very ugly move
um actually just about where you are yes
there are a couple of moves before that
this very ugly move E4
why would you do that and allow the
bishop to always drop back to D4 with a
check Bishop to f8 the king is not well
placed on E5 I see we don't have space
there's no space up here the bishop was
just trapped exactly wow
oh my god oh this move E4 was just
horrendous sighting uh oh and you're
right that's just a he that's just an
extra piece for Alice and she's got this
in the bag
uh with her extra piece wow
foreign
Palace is going to get a lot more
subscribers exactly she has more content
now I think I think I'm going to become
a subscriber myself I've got to support
this uh young lady she's doing
outstanding wow again uh began
also yes I mean they're supporting her a
lot so Bravo
um Jennifer uh my pick how's Jennifer
doing Jennifer his two pawns up whoa and
I think the game is pretty much over oh
boy she she turned this around because
it didn't look to me when we had left it
well quite some time ago longer than I
thought that she had too much
that somehow she won one Pawn
kept it kept it
and now now she's out of danger there
goes the second one and yeah she's got
this game in the bag does Jennifer as
well with her two extra pawns yeah
yeah hey very very nice and finally Anna
zatonski tatsapp made a draw how about
the clash of the US Champions Arena ooh
and the arena actually has won a pawn
for Rook ending against her being
but the extra pawn and the fact that
White's pieces look a little bit more
active actually than blacks and they
just made the time control everybody
actually just made the time control
right now
and uh Anastasia just to remind
everybody our results so far let's check
let's do it yes
the results in uh we have women's
section first and we have how many two
draws at the moment
and also Sophia against Italian and a
nice lost the game against Megan Lee and
still we have four more games to go
right and uh the game that just caught
our attention was Wesley and Alshon
elshon we feel has led a winning
Advantage slip we don't know if it's uh
still winning but Wesley's game was just
roof very dramatic yes he could lose
this game if if Christopher would find
this bishop A5 move easily and we're
going to take a break as a round two
coverage of the U.S championships uh
he's coming back I see you on the other
side
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
and we have results of round two let's
start from women section so we have
Jennifer you we have actually three
decisive games right yes because also
Alice Lee has one as well as we were
just coming on air she resigned so we
have two decisive games and and one more
which is not still here right and then
we have two drawers also today
um Maurice Suzuki made a draw with
Thalia Cervantes and also another
finished her game peacefully we started
um two more games to go yes two games
remaining and in the open section uh we
uh let me just see how many yes let's be
happy we actually had three three draws
yeah we have three drawers and more than
half of the games are still
um are playing and we can we can we
check the games of Hans and even before
but I'm wondering what's happening with
Wesley I think Wesley is now winning it
feels very much like Christopher got on
the wrong
um whoa whoa whoa yes
don't get ahead of yourself really
Wesley is not winning he's not he's
worse it's worse yes I see okay but he's
just what just a second I mean I thought
this was a desperate a Desperado
sacrifice of The Rook he's just played
after the move Bishop C1 Knight F6 yes
okay just a second sorry this is where
we were we saw this move Rook A3 and
there's this fantastic move Bishop takes
A5 which was very hidden that would have
won the game for Christopher instead he
played check and Knight F6 and after
Bishop C1 I was expecting that the game
was over but Queen H4 and Knight H5 is
definitely on the agenda and and
Christian said don't get ahead of myself
wow wow I think you missed that Knight
H5 move didn't you yes sir I did yes
because that's the big move that's why
he played Queen H4 right right just to
get out of the way of the night actually
yes he gave his face to the night yes
gosh and I thought I was breaking
through on the queen side as well how
dangerous is it let's just have a look
like Bishop takes and this is what he
has done you know take and then I don't
know move the Rook to figure out where
for example right and the worst possible
place Knight H5 and then again I just
raise the threat and you have this um
check yes that's a problem
I think oh thank you for that yes
but we also have a guest instead you
have a check on the gifts I have to
guess it over to you we do have uh the
U.S women's Junior Champion Jennifer you
is with us Jennifer first of all
congratulations a great start for you
two out of two yesterday against Anna
one of the rating favorites that was a
big battle tell us a bit about that
well um I'm I think like my technique
there at the end was definitely a bit
suspicious but overall I think it was a
pretty good game
um so they're in I wasn't really sure
like what my form would be coming into
this tournament
um just because it's like AR prep but
you always feel like you don't prep
enough and I've been really pretty busy
with like school I'm like still making
up everything
um so overall felt pretty good about it
I'm really happy the way it played in
the end I think I did some pretty
creative stuff
um but definitely a lot to work on too
let's talk about today's game uh when
did you feel like you're taking over it
felt like the position was complex but
at some point it just broke through
what was that key moment okay well to
start from the beginning this opening
was just I don't know the um
objective evaluation that something is
it definitely wasn't that good for me
but
um yeah so here I like I I knew I
definitely knew I was supposed to play
but um I didn't remember it right away
and then
um I don't know if you guys saw the
broadcast but I knew there was a camera
on me I was like coughing my lungs out
in the beginning
um so I wasn't feeling too good and I
was just like oh let me just make some
moves and then all of a sudden I'm like
what am I doing Bishop F3 now you're
better now yeah yeah
of it I'm just like it's just yeah I
don't know what's going on but um at
some point I think when I started to get
um like I moved my night a bunch of
times but when I got the Knight ti-4 I
started to look um like I started to
have an initiative
92 F4 nice maneuver
Target opponent on D5 Queen F6 Bishop H
Queen H5 okay so this was like really
tricky here
um because she played Rook C5 which I
think makes a lot of sense because now
um even though she like she's losing the
pawn she gets a lot a lot of power play
for it
um so here I thought for a while we were
also both get a little lower on time I
think but here I was like okay we have
to go for this takes but it does look a
little scary here
um because G6 is nice and then create a
lift for uh the king first but there is
like the drawback that the king inside
this weekend
um yeah now here yeah and Rick D2
um so I thought for a long time between
Queen B5 and queen F3 well Queen F3 I
just hated this move
I just I was like this is horrible but I
was like also a little bit scared about
um this birthday too because it just
looks so like black has so many tricks
after Queen B5 yeah but it seemed like
it didn't work like none of them worked
for her even though it was the best move
Queen B5 yeah it didn't work for her so
I went for this
um especially after Queen C6 yeah can we
see six and and like you really want to
get Bishop takes E3 to work here but
it's just supposed to C1 yeah so Bishop
takes C3 that's a nice one yeah of
course don't take on E3 because you get
checked mated
um and then here I think I'm just you
know
um I think she still has counter play
but uh it's like I don't think she has a
really obvious plan on how to continue
here no maybe this move Rook to E2 with
the idea to take on E3
take
Queen C3 and it gets pretty wild yeah I
go F6 but
wild position yeah it's just crazy and
how much time did you guys have at this
point five minutes for yourself and 13
minutes for her and actually she thought
for a very long time for this move Queen
F6
here it's just I think it completely
turns my favorite because now I'm
kicking her Rook back she can't really
um
like there's not that much like you know
her counter Play Chances are kind of
gone so yeah now it's just like very
easy for me
absolutely well
Jenny for a very strong start for you
two out of two what are your Ambitions
coming into this event
well I kind of had a very weird feeling
coming to this event because
um the last time I played this
tournament was
one year 2019. I wanted 10 out of 11. so
because of that it's like any result
other than 10 11 is kind of a
disappointment but obviously it's really
difficult and
um it's been a few years and
um I you know I haven't had as much time
to look at chess
um I just really wanted to like it's
play this tournament even though you
know it's not the most convenient time
for me except midterms and
um all sorts of things so
um I was just kind of like obviously I
want to win because that's my result
last time but I'm just kind of
you know as long as I like play well
keep up with my work you know I'm I can
I'll take it how do you usually combine
your academic career with playing chess
you study at Harvard right that's pretty
demanding yeah
yeah so this is my first time missing
things in college
um so this is like I'm actually I'm
really learning that right now because I
used to do it in high school but it's
like completely different
um so you know I'm just have to put like
time out every day to watch lectures and
do readings like took a little quiz this
morning
um but you know so far so good I just
need a my other goal is to like sleep
it was cashy that would be
um
today
excellent congratulations Jennifer I
mean there's still planned actually not
11 rounds 13 Rounds this year a lot of
games left to play congratulations
indeed our congratulations to you
Jennifer keep up by good work and uh
well I'll help you spend the Bobby
Fischer
prize if you need any help I am
available yes yeah yeah at the end of
the tournament I'll be available yeah
yes sir yes exactly uh just uh turning
our attention to uh the game between
Arena and Sabina for just a moment and
my spidey sense is tingling this move
Rook E4 looks like an error because
Arena has the opportunity to trade the
Rooks now of course you've got the tempo
I would love to play the move Rook to C5
which would win a pawn but it would hang
my Pawn on H4 so I can start
with this nice little uh tickle Rook C4
and you cannot exchange
ending is completely lost
yeah rookie five and now what I want to
do is bring my Rook to the B5 Square
like this yes
in order to
another look at the sun streaking right
across the board and she's done Rook
takes E4 Rook takes E4 will she follow
it up with The Rook C4 and this whole uh
we're talking about Rook endings
yesterday I have this really funny story
was uh after our broadcast I have gone
home and I actually have a roommate
Alexander shabala uh he is the Grand
Master in Residence here at the St Louis
chess club and uh he was giving a
private lesson downstairs I'm upstairs
surfing the internet and I'm hearing him
give this private lesson and then
suddenly I'm hearing our voices
Christian yourself myself and I'm
thinking like what's going on I'm
hearing on and I'm hearing Alex uh
Xander saying
she's going to do it and I hear my voice
said she did it yes it was a 30-minute
delay on our broadcast so it was like
really funny and the private student and
shabala for were going through and they
were following our analysis and it was
almost like a cheer when
Jennifer won at the end it was really
really funny uh the 30-minute delay
caught me unawares do you remember
during the sinkhole Club when we had
this 15 minutes delay Peter and
Alejandro was passing by the the club
and there were people still watching the
a broadcast and while they were passing
they saw them and the silver Castle they
started all to upload
still their own Peter here
this is at one time it was funny what do
you have for us a Christian in this
amazing game between uh Wesley it's just
wild yeah it really is just wild this
bishop takes H7 came out of nowhere but
you do have to get rid of the Pawn on E3
you don't have time simply put if you go
Rook to E2 after right to H5 you're not
in time to G3 is coming you're in big
big trouble actually you're close to
resignation at this point so you have to
do something he played Bishop takes H7
best move in the position Queen takes H7
Rook takes E3 I'm still looking at
Knight H5 Knight F4 ideas but now I have
to worry about Rook 28 and there's no
more Pawn on E3 nevertheless I have one
extra move one of the options would be
to go Queen to B1 go for the B5 Pawn the
problem is the queen is kind of getting
off track for example if you take on B5
I go Rook to E2 and now I'm starting to
look at ideas of Queen to G6 get the
king out of Dodge with King F2 and then
Rook E8 you might be in trouble right
each one I don't think you want to do
that exactly The Rook on H1 is also
unprotected so he played the move Bishop
to C7 which in fact is a really good
move really really good move it seems to
encourage the best books in the position
wow supporting Rook to H2 I like this
idea right the queen is starting to feel
some heat on uh G2 if you go A6 which to
my eyes at least looks like the most
natural move the problem is that I have
this sequence going to be one check I'll
pick this one up you go here and now I
can go Knight to H5 that's one way I can
also go Rook to H2 and once again it's
so much better than the previous one
with the respawn d8 and the pawn on A5
the version move ago right when you
could have played Queen to B1 because
now you have Rook H2
critical move Rook to H2 Queen to G6 and
now Bishop to F4 I can also just simply
take on A6 with the queen and I'm still
going to be better so big moment right
now Wesley needs to uh well find some
really cool defensive resources for
example you're looking at Queen to B1
let's try to defend against that Rook to
B3 at the same time also I'm looking at
opening up the B file and activating my
Rook with Rook to B7 so
big game still a lot of details in the
position still not easy for either side
and this is a three uh result game what
about B6
all the time to ask this question I'm
holding back uh Basics but then I just
take right and I take with the c Pawn
you want to go away one day one day but
the bishop is protecting that B8 square
and this is critical right okay and Rook
E7 let's just Rook E7 I think you might
be looking at some checkmates but let's
try to bring the last piece into the
attack Knight H5 this is actually not
good at all
it's completely over
minus nine minus nine minus nine okay I
was about to make it
Tony from you and it said minus two
I would like okay okay
we're retreating I'm retreating look I
have intimidation you're intimidating
yes I'll take that as a question
especially when I have my good friend
yes stockfish 14. very nice very good a
very good friend indeed okay important
to have good friends
um again from the current position uh
just give us what the engine is
considering Wesley's best place so this
move route to B3 seems to be the best
way forward but it's still not as clear
Rook to H2 and now Queen to G5 Rook
takes F2 King takes F2 isn't that a six
way into C2
this is the draw because now you go
Queen F5 and somehow you have something
here oh come on
Wesley's not going for this yeah this is
a draw yes this is a draw this is a draw
yes I'm going to give you Perpetual
Queen C8 Queen H3 if you go to uh to H7
and you cannot go to G6 because the
Knight is jumping to F4 Wesley is not
going to go for this okay guaranteed
okay so what is he going to go for after
Bishop C7 if not that if not the Rook to
B3 the most natural at least to my eyes
is
feels very natural but then I just go
Bishop to F4 and how do you continue I'm
putting some some serious questions to
the situation to White Rook to H2
oh man this is not going to be an easy
defense for Wesley I'm looking at the
lines and they're so unnatural you give
up the piece and then you go for the
counter play on the other side and
supposedly you still have some good
chances this is not an easy defense for
Wesley he's in trouble after this move
Bishop to C7
Christopher you guys with the black
pieces might be ready to take down uh
the former well great the defending yeah
defending U.S Champion wow and the
current also 960 Champion world champion
yes
I thought how are we doing on time by
the way
yeah
down to his his last 11 minutes this is
the second time control yeah 23 minutes
for Christopher you it's really hard to
defend this position very difficult and
you can see all these threads and this
queen be one check and queen takes B5 it
makes me think that you want as white to
play B6 just so that you can keep this
is very nice clean side alive but that
line with Rook B3 and yeah okay it's not
finding that if he finds that
yeah that would be amazing by the way in
eugenio's uh
acceptance speech into the Hall of Fame
he made an interesting observation that
in 1992 he served as Bobby Fischer
second
in um sveti Stefan and Belgrade and that
Bobby had introduced Fisher random and
that he eugeno was going to Argentina
with Bobby to play uh the first 960
match but for various incendiary reasons
it didn't happen and then here we are 40
years later and a Filipino Wesley so is
the champion of Fisher random so eugino
is very puffed about that that he could
say that back to the game of Hans Neiman
more
today and and game it feels like Jeffrey
has reconciled himself that he is
willing to make a repetition he's been
moving his Bishop between E4 and C6 and
not too much has happened in this one
yes but he's coming to that conclusion
quite
painfully because he's spending a lot of
time he's now down to his last 11
minutes so just to repeat the position
he spent
19 minutes off his clock um second time
I see maybe he was looking for some
winning he's trying to find something
but there's nothing that there is
nothing there's nothing in the position
maybe you can try to transfer the bishop
to F5 but even after that how are you
going to continue
like where's the follow-up I will put my
Pawn on C3 whenever you attack it with a
rook right it just doesn't feel like
there's a big follow-up very good elshon
on the other hand uh at the at the
moment that I left it I thought wait a
minute uh that suddenly elshon was now
back to winning because we had seen a
number of variations where the bishop
was able to sacrifice itself for both
Pawns uh now this is no longer the case
uh alshon's last move Queen B2 checked
uh if I'll just make a move yeah then
suddenly B6 you're not getting both
pawns for the bishop you'll only get one
and that's not enough so
and therefore he won and we have our
first winner uh of the day in the open
section round two and then finally uh
Fabi to kind of round things out
he's one upon good for him
how did you wish to do that I'm still
alive yeah for some reason I was
expecting that Rey might go and take
this Pawn I guess he was a little bit
fearful of
the night coming to C3 threatening mate
and maybe something of this nature
scared them away
and it looks like a draw yes it's very
animated Hans Neiman like did I miss my
win did I miss a win I completely forgot
something yes
yes
very emotional very much at this moment
yes and to
Jeffrey I mean I still wonder why he
wears masks but never mind I mean it's
right because it moves them down
yes we have some bad things right the
nose isn't covered so just I think it's
a matter of habit like you were used to
to have a mask during this years right
personally I found them so offensive on
the ears I wore them on the trains in
Holland guys and uh breaking news please
Wesley blundered huge blunder by Wesley
what right now he's completely lost to
E7 and Christopher you is incredulous
right now after night wage five Wesley
can resign he's getting mated you cannot
take on C7 because if Queen to B1
followed by Knight to F4 right clear
you're losing the queen not only that
but you're probably also getting checked
you're losing everything you're losing
the queen is enough with maybe not only
that maybe but Queen to B2 is coming I
am picking up the Rook as well exactly
this is horrible after night wage 5 how
do you defend oops did he just miss this
I think he'll take the Knight on this or
what sorry I know take one yes
maybe take on each one right but then
ig3 and then I pick up the queen of H1
and he's not even sorry I have Checkmate
in four moves boom boom boom boom boom
boom boom
over
that's it so crazy if he finds Knight H5
this is it Wesley so is going down at
the hands of Christopher you 15 years
young amazing and what a decision he
made you remember yes he repeated the
position yes and with only two minutes
on the clock he played that crazy Rook
to yay the best movie in the position
right but not an easy decision to make
and let's see if he finds Knight H5 guys
this is big right now
is it the only winning move because
there's also this queen B1 queen queen
B1 is definitely tempting but not even
remotely less powerful uh Knight to H5
in terms of strength Nitro H5 just
finishes the game wow
wow really
Wesley understands that guys
let's see so we're going to see the
hover first there's going to be a
hoverboard
here comes the hover no no he's hovering
over the queen queen he's going to go
for Queen B1 very very tempting move
that Queen oh my god oh he's gonna he's
gonna use the heart you know like when
someone is trying to make a move but you
really want him to make right is he
actually the king of fate or is that a
king no no no there's no way
he's actually the other reason why
hovering is such a bad bad habit is
sometimes I'm not kidding you can
accidentally touch the wrong thing
that's true yeah no but it's really
annoying for the for your opponent to
win by the way I I didn't realize it
yesterday but I was playing over the
games and uh Alice Lee versus ashrita
Alice Miss Mayton won
she played Queen takes E4 she had a mate
in one Knight D4 was me
it was like oh
okay
mate one was a was Stronger always but
but taking the piece was very good as
well so Knight H5
and the evaluation is how many points no
plus seven seven seven Queen B1 and the
evaluation is plus one point something
uh it's almost wrong huge difference
just
huge indeed and the class times and
Associates yes I see that it's like
around eight minutes 38 seconds for uh
Wesleyan 10 me and how was 17. 18
minutes
and plenty of time for Christopher and I
do have to say one thing Queen to B1 is
extremely tempting absolutely because
the best move after Queen B1 is Rook to
E1 Queen to D3 and then Rook to E2 and
then you can still play Knight H5
it feels like you're just boxing in your
opponent then you play Knight H5 and you
win right but it's not that easy anymore
right it's actually not that easy one
this was my biggest weakness in chess is
like a move like Queen B1 check followed
by Queen takes beef I saw these pawns
and I thought oh I'm doing my position a
great service by taking away White's
best you know action right and so a move
like Queen B1 followed by Queen takes B5
is just so tempting I convinced myself
in fact it was the best move I I almost
stopped looking for anything better
and there's no choice
are you a trainer or foreign
[Laughter]
forced
on the board
yes and then what queen B5 rookie two
and the game continues absolutely
and you say it's only plus one or plus
plus four plus two depending on how
Christopher let the computer think
um
and rookie two is actually forced
there's just not nothing to discuss H1
is hanging and as you were saying uh
there's two ways to deal with the
hanging Rook on H1 Knight H5 but I don't
think it was happening
Rook H2
it wasn't that Rook what it wasn't that
wrong you were supposed to go with the
other route you too yes so it's mistake
that's a mistake now it's back to plus
six if it goes Luke H2
okay two what Rook H2
he's hovering over it I I can see that
much
so Wesley blocked with the wrong Rook
exactly oh dear Rook H2 followed by
Knight H5
and it's over
we might actually see a resignation very
soon because there's nothing to do
anymore
so you're saying after for example a
move like Queen G5
the liver is the Checkmate on G3 almost
or you have to sacrifice the queen uh
since yes you cannot move anything
you're completely boxed yes right
no the best move right now is to give up
the queen
but I mean if you do that it's over
right Queen takes and King G2 no okay he
he blocked with the wrong route so what
would happen if he uses
well you kind of understand that you
know he was like annoyed you want to
screw right for the king so what would
happen if Rockets do then we just
sacrifice our queen or whatever let's go
Queen G5 or queen G5 and this is a
complete the difference is that I teach
five I take on H2 right right you don't
have time for that oh my gosh it's it's
really hard not the best game of uh
Wesley I must say
he's but it's such a difficult position
to play right well but but including the
move rookie seven which was a really bad
move right I mean that because his very
next move was to return the Rook back I
think he already like maybe he gave up a
little bit these guys never know
they always tell you I wanted to resign
I wanted to never lying to you do not
trust them
okay thank you
yeah no they never and night age cry
very quickly boy was Christopher ready
to what is going on through this young
man's mind right now he lost the
difficult game against Hans Neiman
yesterday but bounced back with black
pieces against the defending champion in
such a dominant fashion
also he made that difficult decision
that is such a huge boost of confidence
to play for the world
but somehow he didn't shake his hand
everybody
we see a hybrid handshake
I think it was like the the two ships
missed one another one
Wesley's hand went out
and then it was ahead and Creations
fist bumps yeah I think it was a
handshake
wow congratulations I mean that was
Wesley's losses and U.S championships by
the way maybe I can boldly State the
offer yes it can be counted on one hand
he he's incredibly consistent draws draw
oh when oh thank you draw drop very very
hard man to beat with the white pieces
especially especially wow uh also we did
see the Hans Neiman game that was drawn
so we actually have two decisive games
this so
and I think Rey and fabby's yes
and in fact uh draw has agreed in this
game as well so as far as the open uh is
concerned the the men I want to say or
the open been very consistent two
victories per round
so far so far
and the ladies have had four victories
in the first first round and three so
far for this round two Arena Crush
though appears to my eyes to be winning
against Sabina and Rochelle
well we're shutting well this is a win
too so many bones now we can count bones
yeah Sabina seems to be right in that
sunlight the the light beam yes you know
just right there
what time is it well it's driving into
the sunlight but it seems like Irina is
the one riding into the sunset with a
victory by the way uh
she
she jettisoned the h
Pawn H4 Pawn did arena in order to win
the pawn on A5 so it was a trade
but it's a very good trade for white yes
because you have two connected fast
phones but the problem is is they're
tortoise-like it it it's really tedious
uh getting the pawns up the board so for
example Rook down Pond here Rook over
right
and you go upon here and your next move
is to go roof yes
on Rook here okay how do you get uh yes
sir pardon me we used to call it the
cat's ladder
the cat's ladder the cat's ladder yeah
yeah I don't know if we actually had a
expression for oh but almost like this
tortoise-like slowness so the point is
so black says go ahead and do your worst
and while you're you know slowly slowly
methodically running up the board I'm
going to be getting some counter play
myself
uh-huh don't uh don't forget that I do
uh can play and this is like three at
the end right yeah oh sorry
Anastasia what you said for example if I
try to escape There Is No Escape right
boy that Sunbeam is really irritating
you could imagine the players asking
could we change Tables
by the way guys I do think that we're
going to see a resignation in that game
between Rochelle and ashrita as well
because yes that one is not going
anywhere anymore no next move will be
Bishop Bishop to D4 and queening uh the
H seven that's perhaps capture that
handshake between the two ladies and
it's going to be forced decisive game of
the round right and maybe five uh
depending upon Arena's outcome but uh
definitely Rochelle if we can see uh at
the playing Hall the game between
Rochelle and her sharifa because we're
expecting a handshake to show up
yes absolutely that this is Bishop D4 h8
uh what's coming it's game over
I guess we don't have our cameras in the
plane mall for these particularly yes
okay there's a particular players
yeah so lots of lots of drama today yes
Wesley lost the game I mean really
interesting game today absolutely and
they're gone in fact that was why we
didn't have a viewer thoughts everybody
everybody left so four decisive games
with one game remaining it's the arena
uh it's the matchup between uh two
former U.S uh Women's Champions and uh
it's interesting that the arena won it
eight times since Sabino one time like
it's such a big contrast to the way yeah
it was one of the most emotive victories
I've ever seen uh prior to the
tournament Sabina yes
and it was almost like I want to win
this Championship
he achieved it yeah he's like ah I still
feel there yes no tears it was really uh
the whole world was watching I remember
the two even though I was not here I
remember that it was very impressive and
moving yes and then we see Sabina really
buckling down and saying okay uh do I
have enough resources here after H4
again I think it's it's vital to get
maybe even with the Rook check but it's
vital to get the Rook behind the pawn
not to allow white to get her Rook
behind the pawn maybe another balloon
and we have a guest with Christian in
studio we are indeed with a proud Victor
of today's round elshon moradia body who
took down the Wild Card Warner young
elshon welcome to the show a difficult
game yesterday against Samuel defended
so well but unfortunately fell short
today on the other hand you bounced back
in incredible fashion tell us a bit
about it yeah well I first have to say
that I feel very lucky today at
uh I misplayed my opening my move eight
eight okay
after okay not eight sorry later on okay
my prep was against against the
was it A4 here I play A4 can you play A4
yeah and that actually is the move that
surprised him actually oh okay that game
you see it's downloaded thrown off
against Marek that was my prep without
what did I forget then okay so that's a
game in the correspondence just that guy
is a world champion unfortunately we
cannot because I gotta look at that no
we cannot look that yeah at that but
yeah so I was expecting something like
25 perhaps Knight A5 is not it's not a
good move I know that you should see too
even yeah yeah this is a slightly this
is I'm good here this is I'm good here
uh okay so then I played the right move
so what are the ideas behind this movie
for because we were discussing this Main
Line obviously is D4 so you got A4 a43
weight and then prepare the move and
because you play the move A4 you have
Bishop A2 the whole idea is that you
keep the bishop A2 an option got it so
so I'm not looking at D4 but rather D3
slowly eventually you want to play
default I mean if you don't play D4 and
Spanish and we play with blacks there's
no difference yeah that is the Oregon
sometimes after 92 you have right wt4 so
okay I played the right moment
yeah and uh
I must have to analyze this and I forgot
I mean I feel very uh past three weeks I
had this immune system run down and I I
I don't sleep well so during the game I
expected him to play this I had looked
at this but yeah so I forgot anyways
then I played D3 which is okay and then
the Knight A3 isn't the greatest one
okay I didn't like this before C5
this most C5 uh I think Knight G5 right
maybe it looks like a nice nice C5 for
him instead we'll go back to my C5 oh
engine likes this for white yeah Knight
E6 then still seems to be favorable and
D4 yeah this this this
corresponding works yeah yeah because
now he doesn't have the right setup with
the rokonia to go Bishop f8 defense
makes a lot of sense so c5s was a good
move
wow I did not know so okay
and uh he played Queen B6 which already
seems to be we were discussing this
that's why I was lit I'm sorry we were
discussing this move that I said I'm not
a big fan of this move at all because
you let go of the five score kind of
kind of but I thought Bishop C6 is a
better move instead of Queen B6 okay
Bishop to C6 that's apparently been
played yeah and then I was explaining C2
Knight E3 and then probably Knight d293
trying for D5 by 5 Square it's still
very minimal but I mean it's normal just
a normal position normal Roy Lopez uh
and he played Queen B6 now
yeah I thought this was probably this
was very concrete really and that was
his plan
yeah I think it's already really bad I
don't know I mean your engine doesn't
show a lot of advantage for me I think I
think that's okay yeah but no nice if I
was definitely losing I mean he missed
A5 he said after the game Knight C5
takes on F6 and then A5 and uh yeah he
missed this one and now Knight to E3 oh
wow Bishop it was Stronger pretty much
they can go over it okay all right 0.3
yeah not a big difference yeah okay 93
then okay I was playing just right about
and I'm winning and I was cruising and
yeah
I'm playing really well
I'm making All the Right Moves keep
going yeah there's nothing much to say
and then okay keep going here this 23
now it's all all yes all good good still
good still good
and then I thought this is and then here
unforgivable from you just take on C5
player V6 I mean just I saw that during
the game I don't know why yeah it's
unforgivable I mean
yeah I saw it I just said okay I'll give
a few checks
why is it so easy what if you just go
Rook to B6 now Queen to B5 I guess
you don't have time to give
both Rooks one Rook for both parts
even instead of uh Knight xc5 I think
that's also winning right
yeah it's even even easier does the job
yeah for sure no I mean I saw I just
yeah and then I picked up the exchange
and then I realized that if he gives up
the bishop for two pounds yeah yeah and
I was like oh my god
well I mean you deserve it coming when
you play faster but you're still winning
he never had this point you're still
winning but I had to find this one
because I had to find it that I get my
queen right right for B6 when he's not
in time to stop E6 and
and as I said I'm I'm not feeling so
well but so yeah I
and you're talking about this point yeah
and then right finally yeah okay yeah I
mean the the more important one if you
go back a couple of moves is that this
is the moment for Queen A4 because not
if it goes
rookie five not having time to play
Queen B3 Bishop B6 and now the queen
goes to C6 with the check and then and
then I'm in time finally yeah I was
trying to drag the king to F6 so that I
can have this Tempo to go check on F3
and go to C6 that's a very nice nuance
excellent game uh elshon congratulations
and also uh Sabina you are the coach of
Sabina still uh yeah we
prep a little bit at night
um but again I have to do my own
preparations in the mornings she she has
her own files I have to check my own
files and then we play accordingly and
stuff so absolutely congratulations
thank you Sean we'll see you in the next
few rounds quick question for you elshon
uh first of all congratulations for your
Victory very nice uh and you're of
course coming into the tournament with
this big Target on your back you're the
lowest rated player in the field
how does it feel uh knowing that
everybody's gunning for you is it a good
feeling or a bad feeling yes yeah I have
a good feeling about about having a
Target on your back coming into this
event as the lowest rated player I think
I started getting used to it so
that's okay I'm I mean once in a
lifetime it happens to you so that's
okay
yeah
excellent It's a Long Way to go so
there's more Targets on my back so yeah
Anastasia you had the question I just
want to say that so far so good so far
so good I'll Sean good luck in the rest
of the journal we'll be fine thank you
so much carefully uh turning to the
remaining game for just a moment we got
Arena Crush versus Sabina uh poiser and
uh
I want to say that Sabina did it in a
way that I'm not a big fan of uh she she
did the check so that she gave the
active uh King to Arena it's still
probably okay but with this active King
I think it just gives white a lot more
options
kind of helped her yes to activate her
King exactly exactly so uh we'll see if
that's like she did play before I just
wanted to say like for example this is
one of those moments where I can just
show an example where thanks to the fact
that you do have an active King I have
such types of options not necessarily
that this is all good or anything like
that but just to show that there are
different things I can try to sacrifice
this Pawn to get this Pawn so let me
just put this on the board once more and
if I can ever get my Rook to B2 then you
see what I mean okay yeah
and we have a guest with Christian
Christopher this is the biggest win of
your career how do you feel you just
took down the defending U.S Champion
with the black pieces
I feel like it's a great Redemption from
yesterday
especially after after seeing their
interview and everything I felt like I
was kind of disrespected and it was also
kind of a wake-up call that I really
needed to improve my openings and
everything
how did you feel after that game
yesterday because you had your chances
as well right and there's some rivalry
between you and Hans it seals I felt
disrespected on every level
why is that did why did you take it
personally I guess because after after
the like after the interview and
everything
just because he said the game spoke for
itself yeah
and you definitely came with a very
combative mindset into today's game take
us through the key I I did feel like I
channeled in a little bit of my anger
from that to play some aggressive chess
today and that's great if you can
channel the younger and use it to your
advantage that's absolutely a good thing
take us through the game Christopher
oh by the way you started with a Russian
how did you come up with that idea
I I just I I wanted to play like an
actual good opening not try to be on
sound just be as solid as possible makes
a lot of sense if you want to be solid
definitely will pick the Petrov but he
did win he has quite good results
against the Petrov he just beat Fabiano
caruana in the same field Cup in a
Petrov or are you aware of that were you
afraid of that at any point
I actually didn't know this time
I only saw the game Fabiano beat him in
the Petra from three months ago I wasn't
aware of the same field Cup game okay
okay yeah and I think that one actually
he deviated quite early on after 94 he
played Bishop to D3 completely different
game now
when were you out of the opening out of
your book let's say
maybe around move 15 15 yes I prepared
it up to this bishop G6 F5
very nice idea F5 and I tweet when
you're also building a nice time
advantage on the clock and this became
crucial to your strategy as you guys
were entering the final stages of the
game were you thinking already about
putting as much pressure on his time as
possible at that point
I wasn't sinking much because I was
moving fast I guess
I'm I I don't know not not in particular
I think it was I think it was more like
it was a difficult position for him to
play but I wasn't really playing for his
time and
did you feel any nerves coming from his
side
because you were he was probably nervous
but of course I can't read into his mind
so I really don't know how nervous he
was but
um
I would expect him to be a little bit
nervous
um
since I was kind of attacking him yes
one thing that struck us is he was
always ready to write something on his
piece of paper did you notice that as
well it was kind of giving me flashbacks
to what happened to him in like the 2015
U.S championship against where he kept
writing these notes like to himself and
then he got like disqualified but
um those were the flashbacks that we
were getting out yes
but it didn't even if he was writing
something it didn't seem to help today
absolutely and uh let's go further into
the game F3 Queen to H4 very nicely
timed Rook to H6
and right now probably his best chance
was to take on e4 did you spot this move
and how did you assess the position
after Knight takes E4 I thought it might
have been like a repetition with take
Sunny for Bishop takes E4 Queen takes H2
King F1 Queen H1 check oh never mind I I
kind of missed that he could sacked this
G2 Punk between two King two and King D3
yeah
yeah and this seems to be due to the
fact that he's coming with D5 or B5 your
pieces are a bit strangely placed on the
queen side it seems to be better for him
but he didn't do it he played H3 which
is a very natural move to make of course
Knight to G5 and at this point it
already felt like you're taking over the
initiative especially due to the fact
that he only had 13 minutes a new 39 and
you were playing fast at this point
um when was the critical moment this was
a big one how he's come up to the
conclusion that you have to sacrifice
what about Queen H3 it was actually more
of an intuitive decision I just felt
like there had to be some huge attack
after and I didn't calculate it that
deeply
um I just I just had the feeling and I
almost kind of missed that he had this
queen G2 Rook F2 defense
and then that he was kind of Defending
everything and I kind of got lucky that
I still had resources after that and
just to show you a nice idea Anastasia
just mentioned uh instead of Knight to
D7 I think it was this point after look
to E2 no no this one instead of Bishop
to d8 I think you had this move
Queen takes H3 I actually saw it
um I I didn't want to play this end game
after Knight H3 King F1 Knight F2 King
F2 Rook H2 King F1 Rook B2 Rook E7
and I saw that it had it was like some
draw with Rook F7 Ricky ever Cafe yes oh
I guess Bishop takes H7 yeah Bishop H7
zero F7 doesn't work
you have to go Bishop to A5 and indeed
he has some compensation in the position
it was just a nice line that we wanted
to show you uh and you did decide to go
sacrifice on H3
and now you repeat it once
and you got down to your last two
minutes
how did you come up with the conclusion
that yes it's time to take some chances
it's time to play rookie 8 and try to
play for a win this one
because you have to draw in the back
again it's one of the best chess players
in the world I sort of yeah I think I I
spent most of my 30 minutes saying just
trying to calculate as deeply as
possible and I didn't see anything wrong
while I was calculating so I just went
for it I just had to trust myself
absolutely and you made the right
decision Rook 28 putting a lot of
pressure and this was a big one did you
even look at this bishop takes A5 idea I
didn't but the next move I actually
realized it and I was like oh [ __ ] this
is that that was that was kind of a big
Miss so it was but I still had to like
psychologically recover from that and
you could still do it right yeah but
here I here I wasn't as convinced for
some reason
um and you were getting down to your
last few minutes last minute actually in
fact at this point I think I might have
actually missed it again I think I just
kept missing it while I was low on time
so you played Knight F6 Bishop to E1 and
after that you just played a pretty much
perfect game I have to say Bishop to C7
a great move Rook to B3 is the only way
to keep the balance in the position for
him but it's not human when I'm actually
curious how does that keep because yeah
yes yes and you actually sacrifice a
piece after a queen takes G5 they take
here Nightwing to Queen B3 and queen F5
is supposedly a draw wow that's insane
it is it is and not human Wesley is not
nobody's going to find this uh he played
rookie seven
and you finished him off in style
Christopher a huge Victory
congratulations guys any questions for
our victim absolutely uh first of all
Christopher congratulations and also uh
you when you burned your clock playing
the move rookie eight and the screwed
the Perpetual repetition
um
you you must have been having this inner
struggle like I gotta play on I gotta
play on and you were calculating uh when
you got down so low on time that was
exactly the point that I was about to
say no he's going to take the Perpetual
because you're so low on time but you
went for it uh what was it that gave you
that courage
hmm I I I I I felt like there had to be
something
I didn't I I for some reason like my
position looked way too active for there
not to be something so it was also kind
of based on feeling at the end of the
day but I did try to calculate it as
well as possible before doing it well
once again congratulations you made the
Bold decision and it paid off well done
good luck in the rest of the event thank
you cheers
and we have one game remaining and uh
Arena Crush has been nursing an extra
Pond uh we think it's winning but uh
that's it's one of those topsy-turvy
endings that uh Sabina has her uh
counter play as well because these pawns
move so slowly up the board and uh from
sabina's point of view if she could get
I don't know somewhere to just read yeah
you know yeah that there there's a this
counter play to be had and the times are
Yes Minister three am I reading that
right yeah
okay and this is going to go down to the
wire yes we always have one game
it's important to broadcast show yes
that we have one game that goes all the
way to you know the the last drop so to
speak the last full measure
um what's going on uh Christian in this
ending it seems like Rook A2 which was
just played might actually hold her
hopes alive I don't even hold this game
exactly because uh Rook takes I mean
again that's a big threat
they're so slow they're like stuck in
mud or something I don't know and if you
go King F3 then you can give a check and
then go backwards King F3
maybe I'm even starting to be tempted by
King H5 in this case you would have to
give me a check and go back I don't know
I have to say the moves are very
unnatural so after King to F3 King to G6
is the best King G6
uh well on the other hand you similar
ideas you you want to try to
dislodge this King so you get to take
the pawn on G2
also also looks good there is a logic
there
the evaluation sorry I meant to ask you
uh how does the compute the engine
consider this the engine is saying that
it's plus 1.7 but I have a feeling uh
that this position might be a table
based straw wow
not with the move King F3 by the way
King F3 is not the best and that's why
I'm saying they're so unnatural the
movie King F3 was not the best it's not
the best and she hasn't played it yet
um King to E3 is the best move yes good
luck trying to make sense
of that I think I think okay just take
all the Anastasia's Funny Bone there
like King E3 what I mean if I just take
the pawn what will happen if you take
the pawn then I go B5 B5 okay and now
it's some sort of a race and maybe I'm
fast maybe I'm faster than you and maybe
you have the circle chat at the end
maybe correct so that's an issue but now
things get very dicey but again I
nobody's gonna play King E3 that's
that's a study-like move yeah you see
you see that figure out why why this
works and this is why it works uh B5 my
gosh King E3
oh boy if you find King E3 absolute yes
I don't know what to say when you go
wow again it's still not clear whether
it's winning or not and the position
Still Remains very competitive you know
even after that
um I'm looking at some lines and they're
just completely Wild
uh please uh go for it for example King
E3 King E3 yes let's go King E3 let's go
with this crazy move right see if it's
winning or not yes 55 yeah okay let's go
H3 H3 Yes actually I don't think you can
take the pawn because I'm going to pick
up one of your Pawns
okay so H3 so H3 you want to push yes
keep going A6
uh Rook A2
B6 okay six let's keep going
now H2 for example H2 sorry no not the
issue no King just six two seven no uh
yes you can do seven better because you
don't allow Rook to go to a cheat okay
by the way she didn't play King of
course
and then she'll try to push a six
probably
whoa yeah say six years this is what she
played okay just a second but this is a
completely different kettle of fish yes
just a second
now we take the pawn correct
there's no Rook h a check there's no A7
A7 I go back with the Rook
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa so maybe it's
because the idea would be 507 and then
if you play rookie two Rook A6 something
like this but you have after B5 maybe
you play immediately okay too yes
absolutely
[Music]
yes this is the possibility of A7 and
then Rook here but who who Queens Oh Yes
actually good question
[Laughter]
I'll make a bishop yes I'll make you
feel better under promotion with the
bishop
um whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
I'm getting confused suddenly Rook takes
G2
the arena played this rather quickly too
what's her idea Christian well she is
down to her last two minutes and 20
seconds
okay you have to make something uh make
your decisions fast uh no Rook takes G3
is just a draw after it says just to
draw Sabrina managed to equalize the
position again it's going to be a race
and it's not going to be easy to
calculate but you have to take the pawn
yeah so B5 maybe rookie two immediately
exactly like why to go for this yes or
H3 I mean you can start with H3 if you
want it's three H3 and then after Rook
to B8 you have to stop the pawns so you
go locator yeah
I was putting the Rook on B7 for some
reason I had it in mind I wanted to play
A7 but H2 would force me to give a check
and that will just be a draw still a lot
to calculate guys I mean but it does
feel like if you want to do something
with the black pieces right now
you have to take the pawn on G2 exactly
I think she wants to do it uh the
alternative being King G4 and I can
understand why she's hesitating yes
because if I mean The Rook is ideally
placed let's just stop there and if you
could play King G3 and take the pawn but
think about it guys with King to G4 yes
I need only one move to get on the H
file with my Rook that is with the King
on H5 I need two moves Ruby seven or
Rook B8 and Rook h8 or Rook H7 after
King G4 I only need one move I go okay
and she takes that's the right decision
oh it instantly came Rook b55 whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa what is she doing what is
going on what if I push H3 is the
problem right because the king is only
four yeah she wants to play okay I'm
promoting first though and I'm from
actually you're promoting first but I'm
promoting with a check and I pick up
your queen right
three she's going for it
I don't say who's winning now
who is fighting I think she missed it
I think she missed this move H3 maybe
number of B8 Irena is in a very
difficult situation right now I think
it's time to frame her mind yeah play
for a draw right now I think she's
better start thinking about Rook B8 and
Rook h8 exactly that part is
is ready for coronation but this is not
easy because you thought you were
playing for a win this whole time a
moment ago when you just played A6 and
Rook B5 losing time and she played Rook
B5 so fast actually this is the moment
when you have to realize you went wrong
and you have to go back let's say you
have to wait two minutes one of the
hardest things I found yes yes
I have a plan I'm seeing it through and
then I realize oops and I've got to take
everything yeah Rook B8 I think Arena
suddenly realizing uh uh uh uh wait a
minute maybe I have to play Rook B8 and
draw yes she's a very experienced player
but it's not this is
you can also play A7 no way seven yes
really okay let's check this one A7
B7
and Rook B7 yes oh yeah the idea is the
same like crook H7 and then I'm just
going to give you checks if you go back
if you go to G4 then I think I can just
push or Rook H7
you're not in time
and before I'm pretty fast with my pawns
as well yes you are so now H2 B6 and I
defend my Pawn on A7 just in time
exactly I don't have the chance of
playing Rook takes A7
wow that you have to save all this okay
then it's not that difficult it's like
you kind of still playing for win right
not really this was a cold shower for
her look at her time Spencer she
understands that she calculated it wrong
she was expecting A7 and just be winning
right this is over right and now she
realized that A7 maybe rook a2m and
she's down to already 40 45 seconds wow
so Rook B8 Rook B7 in order to check
from the
sorry file yeah I mean it's a very
important moment I mean you have to make
a move and it's easy for us is it
sitting here in studio to say oh she's
got to do this she's got to do that and
she's I followed up for another idea but
it's the wrong plan well again she still
has the draw in her pocket
and that's what she missed actually yes
H2 this is what we missed together with
the arena
I also missed it at the beginning we
checked it was yesterday but Rook B7
keeps it alive because H2 Rook check and
you are in time to capture the pawn and
make a draw
exactly
who talk about making a drama out of
this no but through index it's always
drama right what we saw yesterday that
was really by the way guys don't give a
check on it too because then my king
gets off this diagonal
correct
and then I think you're lost exactly so
go okay to First yeah
yep she finds it
mm-hmm
[Music]
no ways no
enough of drama he has too much
too much and we are expecting Rook B7
now
yeah she's a professor I mean she
understood that she is in some sort of
danger and she immediately recalibrated
her approach
good that it was still possible that the
problem is sometimes that you really
cannot come back
anymore that you over pushed in the
position exactly
happens
quite often right yes you're carrying
this baggage if I must win I must win I
was better
yes so now I think we can expect
something like maybe King G4 still
30 seconds yes well I mean it's time for
H2
let's go yes everybody's ready to write
moves right we start the seconds
actually you're obliged to write your
moves Until the End 15 seconds and oops
look at this yes yes yes yes 10 seconds
okay came to four I think she was
choosing between H2 and King G4 right
and again the players were not going to
get another time control they're relying
upon their increments for the rest of
the game 30 seconds for each move
completed completed move is actually
when you press her clock
not just that you made the move look at
my beautiful move your clock is still
ticking yes
remember that
I'm sure there was this kind of stories
when somebody would forget to press his
logo very very very famously in the
world championship match between
Kasparov and karpov
Gary forgot to press his clock and
take for several crucial minutes until
he was sitting there thinking very very
nicely and then Bang
because far off hit his clock so hard
like ah I forgot to press my clock it
was quite something I think it's on
YouTube there's a little clip of it
really oh yeah
you know your opponent pretends that he
didn't notice that right yeah he starts
thinking reaching maybe I'll play this
and then the woman to make a move but
you you press your clock suddenly he's
like oh yes okay I want to make he makes
move forward right quickly bh2
[Music]
and Rook real good yourself looks like
it's on G7 I don't know optical illusion
to be a disaster if it was an understood
truly yes imagine you're trying to to
make it to H7 and okay right
a small mistake
now okay so the game should finish quite
quickly we're extracting Rook takes A7
um
yes I think she's gonna go okay yes
Don't Take The Rook ponies
more valuable at this point
and so what's going to happen is why
it's going to go over here and escort
her pawn and win the rook and Black's
King is going to escort her pawn and
also win The Rook let's not forget no
draw offers so they have to play until
naked Kings naked Kings yes so they will
probably uh play Until the End
this is very common in the situations
when you don't have draw
it looks like she's Irene is not really
thrilled with the situation look at it
no she she is very frustrated because
she started with a very good position in
round one he gets taught to have spoiled
it maybe should have been very happy
about a draw yesterday today she's
nursing this extra Pawn in this Rook
ending I certainly felt at a certain
moment she had the the the win so to
speak uh remember this rookie for a
moment and now she realizes it's a dead
draw yes I mean you spend so much energy
to get finally some advantage and then
it sleeps away and yeah it's really hard
you feel terrible yes on the other hand
this event will last for a long time
forever almost yeah we still have still
11 rounds to go so she will have time
let's say to recover recover or show
some interesting cheers of course and
maybe get more advantages in her games
exactly let's see Rook to be for and we
are expecting again we could easily see
this type of a situation where both
sides are pushing their Pawn to
promotion and then give the Rooks and
then give the Rook this isn't the only
way to do it I'm sure I'm doing it in
the worst possible way
just to explain what I'm expecting yes
before no she didn't play King C5 she
played King CC not King C six King C5
repeat one
like why your players spend so much time
you you can say on obvious moves it's
that everybody has these habits to play
to be concentrated until the end and not
to make any mistakes and I mean we are
taught we were taught how to do it from
our early age because you can display
any position literally you can just put
your Rook on B2 instead of B1 and resign
right so everybody's very careful still
uh
alert
before that that has any chances of
working
too slow too slow
again I'm expecting a move like King F3
oh that you were mentioned also like uh
but key F3 maybe I'll give you a check I
know I was just thinking about that yeah
yeah maybe King H4 is like give me a
check I cover with a pawn and actually
then I'm faster than you exactly
looking for tricks right maybe I'll give
you a chance to oh okay well she went
king of three now we're going to see a
check on C3 followed by Rook 2 C4
pre-move premium no matter what you do
right
just to try it yeah why would you do
this stuff
you're still well within Realms of
equality but
why would you risk it like this
well the idea that she has is like after
King F2 Rook C4 King F3 again I want to
push the pawn Rook B4 now I can't trade
because actually White's Pawn is one
square further so I have to come back
with the Rook
and I'm still in the drawing Zone but
you're right King H4 was so much cleaner
and as you say an associate always
looking to avoid that last mistake
the king of three king of four okay okay
this is why Arena put her King on C5 in
order to build this bridge between her
rook and king
most probably will find the right move
moves still why not to try it okay maybe
give a chance to your opponent to your
mistakes it works sometimes sometimes
not always but yeah
I mean you can imagine if
Sabina takes on B4
and just counts
wrongly right that's the problem
what happened is she counting wrong no
never mind you can take on B4 actually I
think you can take them before
there's no check anymore there's no
check yeah you can just push the parts
yes queen versus queen good point
[Laughter]
good evening St Louis
yes and good night Greece
I'm still changing myself
and it says here we have this uh amongst
our
panelists uh here when we do commentary
when we when we hang Our Queen we make a
blender yes it's always good morning
I know what you say so I think during
the candidates tournament you had to
wake up like at five o'clock right to
for commentaries or four four four oh my
God
so I remember that you started to say
this maybe during that period yeah but
it but as we had it at four our
production team was waking up even
earlier
and some I'm going to play King of four
and it looks like a three-time
repetition yes
they said um
here yes so they Shake handsome the last
game the second round is over one two
three four decisive games in the ladies
section yes four draws as we saw in uh
round one and once again
two wins in the open section keeping
Pace uh with round one
and uh Christian your thoughts of
another eventful round uh to our U.S
championships oh absolutely and I have
to say the ladies are definitely
bringing it in this one the battle of
the leaders between the young Alice Lee
and begging over and what a game that
was for the young 12 years of age
obviously just incredible and now the
co-leader of the women's section and uh
in the open section I mean that that
game between Christopher you and Wesley
so I have to say that was it felt like
Revenge right you were different he came
here to do the interview and he was like
yeah I took it first win uh and bounce
back immediately and what a bounce back
victory that was I think that's the
highest rated player that Christopher
took down in his whole career this is
definitely a pivotal moment for the
young Lads so definitely that was great
to see history in the making potentially
definitely a great round yeah 12 year
old win per hour 15 year old women the
youths are sounding the siren we're in
town we're here to win that was pretty
impressive because Anastasia and once
again all the results uh start with the
open let's check the results so we have
still sam7 tied for the first place and
and also Hans Neiman is also he's also
there and many people follow them
Jeffrey Sam Ray everyone has one point
except the Wesley so and oh Wonder Liang
that's not somebody you see at the
bottom very often Wesley so and in the
ladies uh what the current standings
after two rounds as we've seen well some
people going for the Bobby Fisher prize
yes at least the lady section keep some
chances yes here we come
so we have two ladies keeping I know
three ladies keeping chances to get
Bobby Fisher Price it's Jennifer you
Ellis Lee and Megan Lee all of them they
have 100 two out of two and then we have
Irina crush and uh begging and relative
and Italian and to my other girls you
know with one interesting well enough we
don't have any with one and a half
there's a full point gap between our
leaders and the chasing pack but there
you have it two very eventful rounds of
the US championships and I have to say
once again Anastasia is wonderful
calling the action with you and
Christian and we're gonna do it all
again tomorrow right exactly absolutely
so we'll see you all tomorrow good night
everyone
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited